Hello everybody!
Hello!
Look, okay, we know we're like 17 minutes late, but it's Andy's fault, not mine obviously.
How is it mine?
I have been here for not even three seconds.
And you're already shifting blame.
No, we were like, I told you to be farting on!
I have been- I have been- You did it!
No, no, no, it was your- thing.
I waited for him.
Doki, D-O-K-I.
You were the one that said, have you seen the new Fugi?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't spot it.
Don't spot it.
We had a perfectly good reason why we were late.
We had a really good reason.
We had to set something up very special.
And it was obviously our brilliant ideas together.
Like, we came up with this idea together.
It was a group effort.
um we worked very hard but like we can't show it yet because like we realize uh we realized i guess that it might have been inappropriate in the beginning so you'll see later why it took us so long to get started um also because i had to get coffee because i would have been awake since uh four in the morning um because guys for those who were here in the morning i was streaming uh marvel rivals as always Yeah.
As one does.
As one does at four in the morning.
So I was supposed to take a nap.
Even Zandu took a nap, but I didn't take a nap at all because like, I'm not a responsible person.
I was just a little bit and just like, oh man, this is going to be, I don't know why.
I'm so I'm so rusty.
Is this going to be okay?
I'm going to take a nap and just call my nerves.
and now i'm here and i have red bull in my system and i'm ready to go yeah i have coffee in my system so we're so ready for uh for fortnite um anyway it was my idea because i was like i don't care what we're doing i'm playing fortnite obviously it's like no matter what solo duo collab i'm still gonna play fortnite like if you want you threw like a bunch of suggestions my way and i did consider all of them like oh these can be fun oh this could be really fun and then you just said oh yeah there's a simpson fortnite thing and i just thought you know what yeah you know why not simpson yeah it's so cool he made the entire map into like springfield and everything i saw like the easter eggs around like there's even like you can do the couch gag too like the oh you can i think you can kill flanders which is like oh my god they have super they have stupid sexy flanders as an emo i don't know if you saw that yeah this feels like i'm feeling wearing nothing at all nothing at all yeah yeah and he
shakes his ass and you can the thing is it's an emote so you can put it on anyone oh no yeah do you still do you wait which is the most cursed skin that you've seen no i'm good i have alien i have um i have mr beast so like like the mr beast like jimmy no you don't understand i spent a lot of money on for night just for skins i literally log in buy skins log out wait but i thought a battle pass you have to play to unlock everything why don't you care about battle passes i'm here for the pay to win like i had the pay to skin bro you want me to grind battle passes bro that's too much work i mean i i've never grinded a battle pass i mean i've only paid like twice for for cosmetics Wait,
I think I pre-pressured you to do that one time.
I remember.
Okay, never mind.
Three times.
Yeah, I remember.
I remember I told you the first you to buy the Battle Pass one time.
I remember.
At least I was sober and I didn't get drunk and buy it and think, oh, well, now I got it, that was my descent.
After that, I bought every skin I bought from then on was sober.
It was my Fortnite.
is what my it was just your awakening yeah this was not an this was not a mistake this was the inception it was meant to be it was my gateway drug but Jesus Christ from there it was all downhill from there also sound guy brought Xander up a little bit is it good now I also have a sound guy Xander you want me you want to pause you want to join a team um you need if you need a sound team That's true.
That's true.
All right.
Anyway, sorry.
That was our introduction.
That was Well, welcome Sandu to the stream.
We're now going to be serious.
We're like, I don't know, like we were talking, like, how the fuck do we get to the serious part of the stream?
So without making it awkward.
Yeah.
I think it'll just like, it's important.
So we'll just like, get it set and then focus on having fun.
Yeah.
So we're going to make this, a statement here um but it was just the only time we're gonna talk about this and then like after that we're just fucking fortnighting i i mean technically we we've been um we've been vibing already like you tell like it's not like this is our first time talking together that'd be fucking weird um we've been shooting the crap a little bit yeah yeah i i told zandu about my uh about the VR story.
He laughed at me.
He was like, that's fucking funny.
Like, and I was like, bro, I was crying.
Like, OK, OK, chat, you got to understand the way she framed this.
Like, she framed it.
Like, Doki is a great storyteller.
Don't let her tell you anything different because like the way she was framing anything and then just she doesn't say anything.
She just posts a picture of the corner of her room.
And if a picture could tell a thousand words, I tell you, mate.
But those who did not see the photo, don't worry, I'll give you guys the visual.
So, um, so this is what, oh yeah, oh yeah, and then like, he was like, this looks like lost.
And I was like, I know.
I did think that, but I didn't want to be like, if it's in purpose, I'm walking into the biggest gotcha.
So yeah, this, yeah.
So for those who don't know, I've been trying, I was trying to set up my VR.
There it is.
Is this lost?
Yeah, is this lost?
All of that is tape.
That is, it's gorilla tape too.
Um, and I was trying to put my audio foam on there as a platform for my VR stuff.
And then, um, the ruins.
And, um, sadly it did not work because it's under the fucking vent.
And I, that was the day I learned that, um, hot air melts adhesive.
Did you know that?
That's so crazy.
I did not know that.
no why i didn't realize the thermodynamics what things can melt like not just ice cream what do you what do you think it's called a hot glue gun i don't think i don't know when it's hot it's still sticky so like why is it not sticky anywhere and then i also showed him this so where like i stuck a fucking box in the corner of the room and it worked like that was my solution um hey if it works if it works i did not see the box wait you see this oh yeah here sorry here's the yeah that was the solution i stuck a box on the wall and i have not seen the box that's a new one yeah yeah that's the one i didn't show him but yeah so the phone didn't work but the box did and i put like the vr base station up top of that so that's how i got my vr stuff to work and that's how i was able to do my sponsor all right serious time okay fool it's gonna be awkward no matter what because like we had like yeah i don't think there's any way to like ski it around this so like um so this is like the only time
we're gonna address this and then after that we're not gonna talk about it anymore so we're gonna make one statement and then that's it um but uh this is so hard because i'm going first so like after that it's like no pressure no pressure i'm going first um but then zani's gonna make his own little little statement too so um so obviously a lot of people are very surprised that you know we're here together um and we're talking and we're doing a stream together um but this has been like
wrote this like wrote what I want to say to like I was like I wrote bullet points too don't worry yeah we both wrote but even then I'm like well this is difficult reading what I wrote like yeah I feel like I'm back in school about to do an English presentation yeah yeah me too I feel I'm doing like public speaking right now and like like chat is like our professor and like we just need guys we just need 80% to pass guys that's all we need professor tomato please I just need
Anyway, so a year ago, Zandu sent me a really thoughtful message to apologize.
But at that point, I was like really afraid to respond because, you know, I wasn't ready at that time.
But it was only a few days ago that I was finally ready.
And I tried to reach back to him and want to know if like he was okay and everything.
of God and Nicole together and we had a lot of talk together and also I also want you guys to all know that Xandu did privately apologize to me and I have accepted his apology and because we're all human and we're allowed to make mistakes and since that's what being adult is and we all make mistakes and we learn from it and we're not perfect you know we're human and I was able to forgive him and move on and I'm happy to have my friend back too uh he also wanted to give a few words to everyone before we start and like i said it will be the last thing we say about all of the subject uh because we just want to have fun and around in fortnite and you know go to the springfield exactly thank you so much jokey for that and for that it's your turn yeah it's my turn let me see if i got my bullet points here and if i mess anything up i'm sorry but see if i remember how to do this i haven't spoken english in a while so you'll have to forgive me but um Yeah,
as a lot of people know, there's been a lot of happenings, both online and personally for me, and I've been taking some time away because I felt that that was necessary for me to recover, reflect, and protect my well-being, all that jazz.
And that distance also helped me process everything that sort of happened and gained some clarity about it all.
And I'm not going to lie, it was very painful and overwhelming at times, but I think stepping back was honestly the healthiest thing that I've been able to do.
And I feel a lot better now.
I've been able to connect with a bunch of people.
I've been talking a lot with my dad lately, so that's a lot of fun.
But I also should bring up that I'm not like coming back to streaming or anything.
I'm still taking things rather slowly and focusing on myself.
I don't really know what I'll do in the future, but I hope that we can just play games and have fun today and appreciate it for what it is.
And yeah, basically along in that whole time, I also realized that me and Doki were probably sharing a lot of synchronicity.
similar experiences that I wish I was capable of seeing at the time.
I was misinformed and felt pressured into decisions that I would later go on to truly regret.
And later that I would find out things that I believe weren't entirely accurate.
And I wished I understood things better before reacting the way I did.
And that understanding is what led me to reach out in the end.
And I'm grateful that Doki was so gracious and would even give me the time a day and allow us to reconnect and everything.
So like, genuinely, I know I said this privately already, but like, I'm so sorry, man, and all of that distance that it created.
And we had to go through a bunch of stuff, like apart, instead of being able to be there for each other and support each other, because I do care.
I care back then.
I still care now, and I always will.
And I'm, I'm just happy that we're you gave me the time of day and we're willing to like, hear me out, talk to me, and make amends.
And we can play games and be silly and talk about Kurt's stuff again because I will tell you even during our like big sappy like reunion call and everything she still springs some of the most out of left field things on me talking about like the PP museum which I didn't even know existed until she brought it up oh yeah and then he I was like bro I heard they have like I think they have like Hitler's ball in that in that museum and then and then Zandu was like no that's wrapped Rasputin's peepee and I was like how do you know that I thought that was like the one thing that everybody knew that like there was like was one specific dude that they like for whatever reason pickled it but how would you know he was like that's common knowledge and I was like how is that common knowledge why do you know Rasputin's dick was pickled I thought I thought that's why he was Russia's greatest love machine but that doesn't imply that they pickled his dick no like that comes later it was a story it was
a shame how he carried on but yeah i'm just referencing song lyrics guys i'm just referencing song lyrics please that is not common knowledge then dude i knew it was i was like we're gonna ask chat i was like We're gonna have to ask Chad if that's common knowledge or not Okay,
I saw a few people a lot of people just like well, yeah They did like like he is right bro They'll just say you're right just because they're like we gotta give him that one.
Yo You just like he may have unbased opinions on sandwich toppings But by God he is right about the pickle the pee-pee But yeah like during like the you know our very heartfelt conversations Like, did you hear about the PP Museum?
Like, I don't remember how, like, my, I brought that up, but, like, it was, like, in the middle of a heartfelt conversation.
It was so out of left field, because I can be talking about, like, yeah, I've been, like, making drawers with my dads, and I'm learning how to laminate things.
He taught me how to, like, grill a steak and everything.
That joke, it just goes, have you seen the mega Star You memes?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I was like, no.
gigantic star me yeah running at me like a freight train i felt genuine fear that's my hyper fixation right now that's i i was like because he's like living like the amish right now um so okay whoa that's your you're i am not you said that you said that no no no no no no that's not how it works i have electricity i have electricity and water thank you very much yeah the bare minimum so he's Amish at the moment like he's literally off the grid when because I was like bro what what have you been doing and I was like have you not seen the star meme memes like you know that's very important to me because like that's like you know that was the first thing yeah I was like bro you're missing out on the internet I was like I can't believe you didn't even know what the star meme memes like like it's the one thing you should know about um I think you sent me like three three different memes that you miss that are important you need to study these yeah i think mega star me was one of them yeah
yeah you're missing out bro anyway oh yeah yeah yeah by the way um wait you're done with your your the series because like sorry we started interrupted during the oh no it's okay i that was basically everything and like the just everybody keep kindness in your heart be kind to one another and just focus on your own happiness and that's all that should to you yeah and star me and mega star me and mega star me of course yeah yeah yeah okay anyway so this is the reason why we're late okay okay sandy do it do the thing oh okay so she spent like 10 minutes like no we cannot get started yet i need to make you look like this and i'm like but what about like the thing we both have prepared oh yeah you might want to have to do this after because i don't want you speaking all serious looking like this
so this is apparently what a dokey has designated my outfit for today i am strong you shout out use shout out to the artist i was looking for like a chibi to use because i was like bro this is disgusting it's just a square like i got you gotta be like a little chibi man you gotta be just like a square on my screen and i was like you probably look for a chibi and then i i was like
It's really good stuff.
This is the fate that I have been designated.
So, yeah.
And then like the thing is I made, I like, you know, made it transparent and everything.
I was like, it might not be a good idea to have you, you know, make your whole.
We do our serious talk and you're just a fucking strawberry.
Yeah, I did think about that.
But you were struggling so much.
You could not get it to work.
And eventually you just get up, gave up and said, you know what Zandu?
You do it on your end.
Yeah, you're on your phone.
Yeah.
And then you send me the freaking picture and I, I see that she has removed the background and I just go, you had the time to render it.
And it turns out the reason we were late is because she was rendering this.
It was not the full 10 minutes.
I was also trying to be sure that we were not streaming on Twitch too.
Like I had to do that.
Because that's also important.
I was trying to find a TV because I was like, okay, we're going to have to be late because I don't want you to be a square on my screen because like because that's not aesthetic, bro.
That's not aesthetic.
Everything is a square these days.
Or if you want to get a little saucy with it, you round the corners.
Oh, oh, if I have a locker right now, I'd stuff you in it.
Lisa, that would be back in the locker.
Don't give you a swirly right now.
You fucking know.
swirling again this is why i didn't put the fortnite screen up because i'm i'm my character is an alien with kicks on and i felt that was very inappropriate with my very serious conversation just aura farming during that so i'll put up my game now yeah so i was just like yeah i don't think i should have my my alien character with his kicks on the screen while we're having our little serious stock here um but i swear fortnite has like it's like such a big file now where you already added so much stuff to it is a thick chunky boy yes yeah i mean this game is like what 10 plus years old now it's like don't say that don't say that out loud but it's younger than league the fact that this is younger than league is crazy no it's not yes it is no it's not fortnite was after league okay league of legends no i i know yoki i genuinely think you're wrong Because I was there when League was new.
Yeah, 2009 was League.
Exactly.
Fortnite was like mid-2010s, right?
Right?
Why are you quiet?
You're so close, Zandu.
What?
Hold on.
Fortnite, I'm Googling this right now.
Fortnite release date.
You're literally talking.
talking out of your ass what do you mean this well I spent 10 years on the between them there is 10 years almost a decade I was talking about decade guys I was when I said 10 years I was specifying league so you said Fortnite was older I don't know I don't have rewind on just whoa can't check it DVR is off oh oh my God you actually oh my God the YouTube face is different i never noticed oh yeah it's different whoa they have an intro oh my god i missed out on the intro oh yeah the intro it's very loud oh my god oh my god it is oh my god there's an intro i missed out on it because i was gaslighting you
whoa fun fact about the opening for the simpsons uh the theme song is composed by danny elfman oh yeah i know that fun fact yeah like i actually didn't know that until like last year or something wait that's that's great i'm surprised like has danny elfman ever done anything recently i feel like he's just been like riding off of his like uh bees from nightmare before christmas and simpsons i think he's done plenty more than that dokey like but i do will admit whenever tim burton's doing anything he's usually there yeah like uh the the The first Mission Impossible movie was composed by him,
I believe.
Yeah, but I meant recently.
Also, Sound Guide, let me know the game audio and Xandu is okay.
So you gotta check up the Fortnite audio that you use.
Everybody's saying Daft Punk.
Wait, he wasn't Daft Punk?
No, it's because my skin is Daft Punk right now.
Oh, okay.
For a second, I thought, I was like, wait, but he's an Oingo Boingo, not Daft Punk.
where the fuck oh yeah that was his that's his that's his band oh he's what well yeah danny elfman's band but he has a band called oingo boingo you didn't know why the would i know about his secret indie band oh i don't know i know about it i thought you were hip with the memes dokey okay i do not think danny danny elfman is like hit with the memes if anything that just ages you by 20 like and i feel like the zoomers are not relating to you right now like what but the zoomers still get i told you you were living like the amish he was living like the amish guys okay oh my god you see it you did you see the shop you see stupid sexy flanders right i'm gonna get the oh my god that is him i'm gonna get that is him i remember that episode episode like give me a sec let me i need a high i'm gonna get the battle pass this is important wait i don't need 1 750 all right 30 i've got this i said you're just opening your wall look this is important i told you i told you i'm so sad i missed the repo
skin i'm so sad i didn't realize it was only in the shop for one week guys how do you think i feel i don't have miku on my account door miki always comes back i think i hope she does she does so i can buy her again guys at epic when can you please put miku back in the shop wait did my pass did you have it oh my god i have it oh okay dibs on homer oh okay let's do homer okay dibs on homer i got homer wait how do i wait a minute they're not by you 10 you have how the fuck does okay to be fair like i feel like fortnite battle pass looks so weird and oh i got mine okay clean up i mean i never understand how the battle pass works or anything so the first time i ever even bought a battle pass it took me ages to figure out how to level up in it oh goodness i have a dog wait i have dad he's here too Homer at the very,
oh my god, Homer's at the very, okay, I guess I'm Marge now.
He's at the very end.
Oh, you gotta grind to get Homer.
Oh my god, I actually do have to grind this game.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, there's, you gotta be Bart.
You have, bye Bart.
I'll be Marge.
I'll babysit you.
Oh god, I gotta get my wallet then.
Hold on.
No way.
It'll be a good investment.
You can be Bart while you wait for Miku.
but i think this is a new guy gonna add all the payment information it's fine it's fine it's fine it's cause i love peer pressure wait there's like oh it's it's it's okay wait i can have homer's car for 2000 that's a steal give me a second i'm gonna buy homer's car all right yo speaking of which yeah did you ever play the simpsons hit and run yes i actually did it on stream and it was
levels the last two levels oh i never got that far oh you know yeah you're a quitter you're a pussy no i was a stupid kid that did listen back like this hit and run let me educate like the ones that are not aware this instant hit and run came out during a time when games had this cool thing called codes and those things were not something you paid for that were like dlc or anything you just inputted that on my pause menu and then you got to have fun did i ever play the story run no did i unlock all the cars and made them jump into the skies when you honk yes wait so you wait so you like you like missed out you didn't even experience the fun you didn't even experience the full experience of hit and run okay you could argue that you could argue that i didn't experience the full experience but i got the good part of it at least that is not true that is not you're not a real gamer until you beat uh so unless you're not a real gamer you're just opposing you were not molded and built from
simpson hidden right you did not experience the the real childhood i i've i've been molded by plenty of other rage inducing games i think i'm good it's not the same it's not the same you lost a piece of you today okay just because of that you're gonna have i'm gonna have to like find a ps2 copy like i think it's on ps2 i used to play it on xbox just emulate i'm just gonna have to i don't know how to do that how do you how do you like i only know like emulators for like way way back in the day for like the game boy advance oh yeah yeah i know about that yeah we can say that that's about where where my knowledge knowledge ends that's actually my little my little programming knowledge is actually due to that oh yeah yeah oh my god i'm looking at dance emotes oh my god what the what the fuck what is the spark look at my dad watching you shop is this what this is yeah look at that look at him dance look oh do you see my kicks you see the kicks he has he's he has oh it's this they look they
look like converse yeah yeah they are they are in converse oh my god let's go he's ready for warped tour oh there we go see this this is if he never retired this is what he'll be doing oh yeah they did retire yeah they fucking blew up and exploded and traumatized me because like they did it in a way where like it seemed like they're gonna a new album and then like they didn't yeah it so like it was a video and it was like a timer and everyone's like oh my god like a waiting room like oh my god what is this a new album and then literally after the timer ended it's like this the um the other robot tomah was walked in the center and then he just fucking exploded and it's like the end so they made a whole like big PR thing,
like hyped it and everything, got people excited to say, lol, we quit, bye.
Yeah, lol, we quit, yeah.
They had an announcement and then like, you know, I cried.
You know, it was weird.
I have come to make an announcement.
Oh my God.
Bye.
Guess what's in the shop?
Zen dude.
I will tell you this.
Yeah.
It's starting to show up in store.
I've seen it.
What?
I saw pictures of it.
I have actually seen it.
You can be a skippity toilet for Halloween or for next year and this year too.
I'm buying this.
I doubt it.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
The spark?
I doubt it.
I think you can stop what we do.
And skippity.
It's the hardest song I've ever heard come out of Ireland.
I doubt it.
today it goes so hard see this is my retail oh yeah i got aliens too all right and then the others are not oh my god wait there's a cross crocs are in the store crocs i repeat crocs are now i'm buying it okay but do you wear socks do you wear socks no of course not what the fuck that's why why would you're such a dad you're such a fucking dad like you're so you're so dad core who the fuck wears socks with their crocs the poor boy just gotta go outside and do a little errand why the with you why are you wearing socks you do not have it is snowing dokey it is snowing do not have heat in your house slash apartment but if i have to run outside you think the heat just like oh sorry king let me come with you yeah but okay then like that's on you for wearing crocs outside during the winter i don't want to i don't want to string up shoes and everything just to go out and like throw something in the garb oh i would just slip into yeah oversized shoes so then you do you not have a shoe horn no
because okay no i have like oh my god look look at him he's wearing wait wait oh my god wait wait why is he not why is it on screen why why is my fortnite not knows that you're talking nonsense and it's just like No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I just bought my crocs and I want to show it.
Look, look, look, look.
Wait, wait, it has to be on the spot.
What am I looking for?
Look, look, look, look, look, look.
I doubt it.
This is a croc.
Sorry, this was important.
Anyway, go back to your regular conversation.
I genuinely have no idea.
I'm sorry.
I got hypnotized by this spark in the crocs.
I know it's so good.
See, okay, guys, by the way, oh my God, I forgot to use my crocs.
I forgot to pay myself I'm so sad you're welcome epic hit me up if you need me to do it again I forgot to pay myself I spent so much I thought I had it on I forgot you have to like re-enter your own creator code okay by the way guys to make up for me not using my creator code I would really appreciate if you if ever if anyone ever buys anything up right now they use my creator code on fortnite um if miku ever comes back i will buy her with your creator oh thank you i really appreciate i think i spent like 50 right today i think i just spent 50 on fortnite today i have a problem anyway oh yeah did you put input your money in what no i literally said that i was like i can't i can't be like don't wait oh my god march with crocs oh my and skip Okay,
I'll go get my wallet.
You can be, look at, you can be so fashionable, just like me.
Okay, while he gets his wallet, let me show you my locker.
All right, so I have, obviously, I have both of Dappunk.
I have Tomah and Guy Manuel.
I have Beavis.
I have, oh, I have Ninja, too.
I have Ninja and Eminem.
Like, I told you, I just go on Fortnite, buy the skins, maybe play it one or two games, And then I repeat, I repeat the cycle.
And then there's Snoop Dogg.
These guys are not important.
I freak.
Wait, this is the best purchase of my life.
This is actually, oh my god, this is actually, I'm so happy.
I bought the Crocs.
Obviously, I have Peter Griffin.
I have Bender.
I have Alan Wake from Alan Wake.
I have, oh my god, wait.
Wait, I had to, oh my god.
Oh my god, to show him this.
I have Mr. Beast.
He has that in the Meeseeks guy.
I have John Cena, but I can't really see him right now.
He's sort of invisible.
I have Goku with Crocs.
I have an...
Oh, and then...
Oh, apparently...
Yeah, I have this.
I have Alien with Crocs, too.
I...
And the Batman who laughs.
Okay, I gotta show him this.
with the with the skippity toilet too all right okay and then these are like the emotes i have with a drop i do i doubt it i doubt it i doubt it i don't but i don't but i don't jump i do i doubt it
And then, okay, I have And then, like, it's hot Drop it like it's hot Drop it like it's hot And then Obviously, the most important one Oh, oh, oh Oh, but got them style I tried too much Oh, T-T-O-G-O You can take me On to go D, D, O, G, O.
Oh, and obviously the macarina, too.
A-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
A-na-na-na-na-na.
Oh, yeah, you can't sign.
Oh, it's so good.
The macarina.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, let's see.
A macarina.
And that'll get gritty.
Oh, my God.
I have so many.
It just keeps adding up.
I return as wallet.
Wait, wait.
Look what?
i have okay what do you look what i have look look what am i looking at look at this oh my god is that nice yeah look what he's wearing oh no he's ready isaac with the cracks look at him go oh my god and also look at this guy wait what what's on what's on his back what is that It's about freaking Goku.
Goku with Crocs.
Oh, it's a skibbity toilet.
Of course it is.
I told you I spent $50 today.
I think I see Mr. Beast.
Is he right next to Isaac?
Yeah, no, I even have Ninja.
I, you know, I didn't.
I mean, Ninja makes sense.
You know, I wasn't a sponsor with Ninja.
I actually interacted with Ninja.
Oh, that's cool.
Yeah, I interacted with Marvel Rivals.
That's neat.
Yeah, I couldn't believe it.
Did you win?
Yeah, we won.
We were against XQC.
Bro.
You got that dub.
That's what I like to see.
Have you played Rivals or do you know like the gist of Marvel Rivals?
It just looks like Overwatch, but with Marvel.
Yeah, yeah, basically.
So there's this character called Penny Parker and like she has mines and stuff.
So there's a special.
So we were doing a sponsor in Rivals where basically it's like street, like it was showcasing the newest season early and they were they wanted us to show this new game mode um where like you can play like the same like everyone can choose the same character so my team we were like let's all go penny parkers and we were defending so like penny parker her her one of her main abilities is that she can set up mines so there were six of us i don't like where this is going so so what we did was we just we just put mines on the entire point and no and like xc and his team could not breach the point they just kept exploding like they would come in and we just threw mines at them and because they couldn't walk anywhere and then they were like they were like those fucking cringe lords they tried so hard and then on our side we're like hit mine like They're like,
oh my god, these fucking try highs.
Like, they want to win so badly.
I love when things like that happen.
When you see, you just know that the other team is like, they're strategizing.
They're thinking of every possible move.
And then you see the other strategizing on the other team.
It's you guys going, mine, mine, mine.
Bro, the thing is, it's like, no, my team was.
It was me, Ninja, Tim the Tatman.
I was like, I was like, bro, what the fuck do you mean we're a tri-hiding?
I'm Ninja and Tim.
Like, we are not tri-hiding.
That sounds like a blast.
I'm kind of, I've been so out of it.
I haven't watched like, like barely any streamers.
Like my content, like as of, for the past six months, I'm not joking, has been YouTube shorts.
I've been watching so much YouTube shorts.
I have seen men in their backyard cook so much meat.
I've seen so much meat.
be cooked.
You have no idea.
No, I didn't.
I showed him.
I showed a screenshot of my YouTube shorts algorithm.
And he's like, oh, don't worry.
It'll get better soon.
Like, you just got to keep watching.
And then I was like, yeah, I was just like, oh, don't worry.
It's usually garbage in the beginning.
And once it gets used to what you like, like it'll start recommending you good stuff.
And so I'm just, when Doki just goes, oh, I'm like, that's like my whole shorts feed.
Like this is peak content.
I was like, yeah, this is, this is my algorithm.
I was like, what, I was like, what do you mean, Garbage?
I, I watch this all the time.
I see it and I can hear the AI voices.
They're just like from looking at it.
I can just like hear it like, when this happened, XYZ went on to be so.
The algorithm is not that bad.
I don't remember what my shirt, oh yeah, what my shirt.
your algorithm was oh oh wait no actually i'm too embarrassed to show it on stream you maybe you're right yeah it's okay it's okay you can take certain things to the grave don't worry yeah yeah all right i'm ready did you buy bart yet uh and okay final yeah where is he do i buy the bat i don't know how to do this do i buy the battle pass you know he's in the regular shop he's the only one you can get on the regular shop simpson here view offer is this the one i I get Bart Simpson,
I get...
You scroll down.
Lego Bart and...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bart Simpson skateboard.
I think there's a purchase.
Oh, my God.
I wish I bought the...
Do you know there was an emote for...
What was it?
Pineapple pen?
Pine...
Oh, the PPAP?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So there was an emote on there, and then in the Lego version, it looks like she was holding a dildo.
Wait, I'll show you.
Okay.
Like, me just trying to, like, calmly process what you just said.
Before I even get the chance to finish what I'm about to say, you just go, I'll show you.
Yeah, I will just feast your eyes.
Okay, here you go.
I have a, here you go, okay, let me show you, okay, here you go.
Wait.
Oh, shoot, wait, hold on.
I just realized, uh, wait, how do, oh God, how do, why are you doing this?
why is this in french oh okay the intro is in french by the way all right here oh bonjour okay wait oh yeah here okay it's like very youtube poopish because of the editing also i'll post it on uh on the chat too like uh oh god this is so hard to do in a laptop but i only have one monitor This is...
Okay, there we go.
This is very important.
Okay.
La dance...
What?
What the hell is this?
I thought so I was like, Oh, I forgot
to say...
There's so many...
Oh, God.
The vine boom.
Yeah, I told you.
It's like YouTube poop.
It's like the brain rot.
By the way, you guys can tell I had caffeine earlier before the stream.
Yeah, and she bites her lips, too.
Why would you notice that?
What are you paying attention to?
Because it was on my 4U Twitter.
You're like, what the fuck?
And why was it there?
She's holding a pen.
Guys, she's holding a pen.
I know it looks like something else.
Now we know that Doki just casually looks at like Lego dances.
There's someone out there that's into that.
You know that, right?
Yeah, what's the term?
Bricked up?
Yeah, so you know how there's like Minecraft porn?
you know there's someone out there unfortunately yeah see he knows about it so i'm not the freak here like i'm not the only freak here
so see so i'm thinking if people can like you know you know with minecraft then like i won't be surprised it's also like you know as if we're supposed to relate yeah yeah you know what talking about guys you guys are you guys get it right i won't be surprised if they feel the same way with lego because they're both like blocky right so like it's the same thing that you know they're blocky minecraft is blocks lego's are blocks like would that like hit the same it's their minecraft lego it's like it's like game lego like it's like video game lego if you think about it i mean yeah but i meant like is there actually like properly licensed minecraft lego crossover there is there is okay i guess that makes sense i just haven't seen it oh no i've seen it as a connoisseur of uh minecraft because of course everyone knows me but for minecraft i haven't touched minecraft and god knows how every time i touch minecraft i commit a war crime apparently how would you like context would you i i'm i'm
i'm i do but i'm also kind of scared the answer okay so like basically i have my own um smp server for my dragoons like for my members and um i i get on there once a month um to like to do normal things you know like make sure like define normal you know since i am the owner of the server i want to make sure that you know everybody pays their taxes and no one decreases the productivity value of doky land um spell with
name um and you know trying to make sure that you know everyone is doing the right good good things i'm looking at your chat and like they're giving you they're giving you the eye right now crime you know when people commit crime you gotta you know you gotta teach them a lesson and you gotta see like there's like there's like you know okay so you know there's like you know uh because i the owner of the server i'm literally the um i am the authority maker as well you know i am the law obviously because like i am the law so i made a jail cell out of bedrock i see i made a jail cell out of bedrock does it have a door and each it's a jail cell okay that answers my question and like i you know i always i pay visit to the land of my people um just to be like hey like also i close the server because like i have loiterers there like i have actual like what's that word when people like live in your property um squatters yeah i have squatters so i had to close the server every time i visit the
server so like they would literally squad on my land how does that happen in mine they would they yeah they squad on my land and i don't like that so so i've had your land it's not even like you found them in your attic it's just like get off of my property like every time i like kill them they come back for some reason so i started closing the server every time i do a little my little tour um you know like when i was gonna say when the queen but um long left the queen but when the king goes to the outside his castle and outside the palace um to like be like say hi to the people that's me uh but i close this like you know how i say hi to the people but there's like a giant gate blocking him from the people uh so you can only see him from like 10 miles away that's me when i come visit uh the server so you just see it like you know when you're playing left for dead and you just know that when there's like a big audio queue you know that there's a tank barrel barreling towards you that's
basically what they feel they hear that sound effect in their heads and they just turn towards the skies knowing that someone is there i'm coming the duchess is coming she's gonna log in the server soon but yeah so um i would visit people's properties and to make sure um to make sure they don't mess with me i take i take a piece of their animal you know like you know like any of their pets or animals and then i put in my jail cell so like you know if anyone you know fucks with me and well it's like what do you mean it's like a hostage situation you know so like if they okay yeah like i need a bargain you mean by a piece you know like a piece what do you mean animal well okay it was like okay i had someone that committed a really bad crime on my server so basically i what like i locked him in my jail cell blowing his nose too aggressively no it was so bad it was really bad so i locked him in my cell but i put him in another miniature jail cell and i found where he lived um because i was
like admins tell me where he lives and then like we TP to his land and we found out he owned a horse.
So I took his horse.
And that was his sin.
So I took his horse and I TPed it back to the jail cell and then I was like, say you're sorry.
And he refused to say sorry.
So I killed the horse in front of him and
I killed the horse in front of him i'll say and to teach him a lesson um i got a picture frame and i hanged a piece of the horse on all four sides so whenever he turns around he'll see this dead horse wherever he goes anyway i have i come on the server once a month so i'll see i'll come back next month to see if he's sorry
i'm not sure what to say to that like the thing is as it was going on i was just kind of like okay this seems like you're like your usual dokey affair and i was a little bit amused then when you said tp the horse i thought oh i had like i know you mean teleport but i just imagine you like wrapping it in toilet paper and that would have been you know that would have been mischievous enough and then as it goes on it's just like i just saw like just to fade in across your model just as you kept that sentence just kept going oh my god there it is there it is there's eric i see him i see now i'm hearing him you're like there's no way she could possibly make it worse but no okay look i had to make an example of him because if i make an example of this really bad criminal like now my kingdom knows not to mess with me it happened to you too like i will find your pet i i know where i know where all of my people live
so it reminded me to whenever if i ever play minecraft with you make sure that you're not to the admin of the server world
Jesus Christ Also, I know I know the influx Also, like before I did all of that I was turning random people's builds into bedrock Just for fun I was like This building over there Turn it into bedrock And just like Out of morbid scientific curiosity Yeah What like what is this game you what is this what do you get at it's just fun you know it's just it's just and they couldn't do anything about it because the server was closed so so they could just watch me turn their turn their entire home into bedrock they also built okay they committed the greatest crime too in my server they built pray tell what did they do lower the prop my property value of jokilon How did they do that?
They built a fucking graveyard next to my land of some apparent crime, like a crime that they falsely accused me of.
Like it's not my fault they died.
So I turned their church into a bedrock.
To be fair, churches tend to be built out of very sturdy materials so that they stand for a very long time.
Okay, you see?
but churches used to be called sanctuaries and technically a wall will mean that it's a very yeah safe sanctuary safe for no one because no one could get in but yeah so now i won't be able to i'm trying i'm trying to work with me here look it's their fault they lowered my property value i was there first i cleaned that land first so like i put and also walled it off so i won't have
so that's what you just like whoever the architect was for this rubbish yeah exactly i said i was like how dare you what have you tried really hard they try they try to lower my property but they try to falsely accuse me of a crime that i did not commit so in my eyes that's ugly they even wrote a book too they're like look at all these drag oh no they that i took the book they made the dokey compendium i took the book and i put it in my jail cell so no one can access required reading yeah no so no one can access it because only winners write the history i mean technically yeah if play if playing military shooters on the play on the xbox 360 taught me anything it's that history is written by the victors so exactly so it was unsanctioned writing it was an unsanctioned book i did not approve of this book and then it was and put it in my jail cell so no one can access it apparently i found out the admin undid the bedrock for the church because i it was you know um unjust which i don't know
what that means uh okay which i don't know this word i don't fucking know what he meant by that so the church was restored apparently but that doesn't mean like that's not going to stop me.
I'll come back next month to do something about it.
It's just like a month a monthly sort of like calamity that pulls through.
Yeah, Geneva Convention.
What the fuck is that?
This is Minecraft not New York City where the UN is.
Like we there's no United Nations in my server.
They're limited to space.
all right i have bart bart in a some sort of i don't know if that that's his like go cart or something that turns into a mech oh yeah oh yeah yeah apparently because like he's too short they do that for like short characters if they're too short they put him in a fucking mech suit for some reason because for the hitbox yeah it's for like the hitbox and everything because that's what they did for rick and morty there's rick and morty man i don't know anything dude they have everything they have like i wish i got the reef i'm sad i missed out on the halloween skins because i really wanted the repo skin so badly like when they start dancing it's so silly all right let me i don't think i've seen that wait you haven't okay guys give me a second this is very important yo we're never gonna get started it's a one hour intro before we go into the simpsons okay repo dance important i also show it to you guys too
they don't make music like that anymore i feel like like really catchy openings yeah it's because like it's only written by like people who are really good at piano and like are trained in like classical composing so but most people these days are just they sit down at a computer and press a few buttons i should know yeah or they just don't do openings anymore because they're like we gotta go to the show so i sent it to the chat first before i sent it to you because they deserve it more what in the world is this it's reborn fortnite skin
that's why i was so sad i hope it comes back to the store they even put the among us they put the among us backpack back in the store too and i still missed it out i'm not so busy i'm so sad the among us i'm so puzzled at what it is that i'm seeing yeah look how tall that's what i'm saying they have to make them tall for the hitbox huh they have to make it so i'm sorry i'm just mesmerized by this dance
it's so good i like the comments you see the comments of no i don't i don't have tiktoks i can't open oh don't worry i got you
Oh, I got you.
Oh, yeah.
Yesterday, after Zandu made his tweet, he went off the grid again.
And then I was like, I was like, do I want to see the fan art of all the people that drew you since you returned?
I was just like sending him screenshots of like.
I'm, yeah, I'm not in like any sort of like headspace to be on social media or anything like that.
So I've just been like, if I ever need to do anything, it's just like, goodbye.
And then I go back to watching television television so joki was so so nice and just like hey i know that you're staying away for your own good and everything but here's some pretty art and i'm like oh thank you people are so nice and then and then here's strobe yeah and then this strobe why are there so many of these why is this a okay so i at least i'm not the only one that thought of patrick from yeah it looks like that it's just like star me all right i'm wait i almost invited this random random dude on my friend's list i don't know i invite tapari i should also let me change make sure that the connection is also uh i'll do east coast uh so it's in the meta great god i need to remember how to wait how do i change my ping okay matchmaking yeah don't need to do west coast i don't even know like if that's how to do it oh if you're wondering why i'm level two it's because i played a test game oh yeah yeah we're gonna i'm so happy that you're level two so we can go against bots yeah i
forgot about that look at the map look at it isn't that cool it is pretty cool isn't this cool the fact that fortnite has turned into like this grand crossover event that we never really brothers is actually kind of cool i never imagined this is the kind of direction it would take yeah i think the biggest mistake was that they made fortnite competitive i think it being a casual game is just to fuck with like just to fuck around is what makes fortnite fortnite did you know they had a game that's why zero build is king yeah i don't know this is okay i don't know this zero build i don't know if they have zero is this zero build they do they do okay no but for the simpsons oh they do i check that oh thank god nice like they had a i don't know you know this a game mode where it was like um it was like uh a game mode i'm trying to explain it basically like your goal is to be the to like work together as a team with mics to be like the last one alive so you have to like ally with people and
be like you're on a team you want a team no kill no kill don't kill me let's work together and then like they work hard to like not kill any like to like be alive and not kill anyone with mics and everything and yeah it's called the lulu yeah
How often does it actually work?
If you win, if you get, if you win, you get like this like special umbrella or something.
Also, I've accidentally dropped this into build.
So, oh, yay.
Yay.
I have no idea how to build it, Fortnite.
Me either.
Yay.
We've only played zero build.
I played zero build and only up, and I'm already stuck.
Oh, I, no, no.
And the Uno one.
I don't remember.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about that one.
I don't remember what we said, too.
I remember I told no one about it.
I'm stuck.
I'd be like, I don't tell anyone how to Uno.
Oh, my God.
My sensitivity is like...
Whatever.
It's...
Wait, where are you?
Where's my...
Where's Bart Simpson?
There you go.
Where's my son?
You want to crank it?
What?
Oh my god.
Battle run.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Oh, thank Otto, the bus driver.
Oh my god, it's so cute.
All right, we should go.
Wait, how do I thank the bus driver?
I don't know.
Let's go to Evergreen Terrace.
Let's go to...
Okay, we might die, but let's go home.
We gotta go to the couch.
Oh, shoot.
I fucked up.
Anyway, I'm on Shenron right now.
Oh, stop.
oh okay i i needed to think about like who are you talking about and then oh yeah dragon ball right yeah i'm on shenron look look at me go bro everyone wants to go home let's chill what can we people yearn for television guys they're starting they're mining they're mining right now i'm scared oh my god oh my god even the sound effects that's so cute oh my god i don't know how out of but hey are we friends oh my god we're not friends he's trying to shoot me wait i think don't get knocked out the first thing you do i don't knock people out because these are bots okay this is you say that but it'll be really embarrassing if we lose these bots are building what the battle hammer seven what the fuck okay yeah these are bots oh my god oh oh it's okay i'm i'm home hello wait i hear something oh wait we're in flanders is home i thought this was our home yeah hi liho hi liho neighborino okay so um i need okay i got the heels i'm i'm healing i'm stimming thank god thank god we're doing a build
on we will be the first uh no build in build to win win in building by doing zero build it's like they're it's like they're bots or something i'm a little bit i'm a little bit torn about this because yeah playing against bots is like yeah but we can explore yeah and we are in build right now so like you gotta take what we can get what the yeah i'll i'll take this i'll take what i can get i'll take what i can oh my god this bot is trying to build that's so cute look at him go look at him go no does he know i'm a real person that was sad little does he know i'm a real boy all right where's wait no this where the oh wait there it is there's there's our home all right i want to see what else is in the neighborhood we don't want to go home break this window what is this oh shit all right i'm chug-jugging all right come sit on the couch son but how do i send the couch how do i know i sit oh shoot someone on me someone on me yeah it's a bot if you die to a bot it's on you i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna bail you out or your full hp you don't need to get bailed out yeah okay oh god yeah the the bots and jesus okay yippee actually we'll grab this oh wait there's a chest that's so cool i love how it's everything like um self-shaded too yeah the fact that they were able to mix all the art styles is yeah kind of impressive the fact that yeah it's like 2d and everything it looks really 2d i love this i don't even know how that works like graphics programming is something i do not oh my god look i'm in my i'm in your room wait wait hold on i want to see my room i don't even don't there's the room oh my god i can be like wait don't get out of here i pay for this house You didn't want to come home when I told you to.
Where are you?
Oh, you went upstairs.
I was trying to climb in through the window.
There's my room.
Can't keep me out of my room now.
Okay, go to your room.
There, this is your room.
I've never actually known how the layout of this house actually works out.
I know that people have figured out the family guy house.
Look, look at this.
Look, this is so cool.
room it's not but you were so confident that's where why are you looking at this dude don't what this this is this is not your room get over here hold on that's just a guest room you're just in the attic where your uh where your evil twin brother lives look here look at this oh yeah oh my god treehouse of horror reference yeah look see let's go i actually had treehouse of horror on dvd i I got it for my birthday from an old class.
Oh my god.
I have like, I used to own like all the, um, what is it called?
The, uh, you know, like the DVD season DVDs and stuff that they would do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I used to have all of them until, cause they were like, they were shaped like the, uh, the heads and stuff.
So I would like own all the way to the heads and everything.
And it was so cool packaging.
And they would have like the main menu would have like special, uh, animations and stuff that they made to make it.
like dvd menus used to try yeah look see this is your room it's actually so cool how detailed everything is you know that there's a lot of attention to detail and callbacks to the actual show man i love that yeah there's like mo's tavern too they put mo's tavern as well my favorite place to call oh wait you okay i was gonna say who made that wait we can wait there's there's the car i should wait what's here look look like homer's car yeah there's homer's car oh get over here get in we're going to school all right where do we go i'm sitting in a booster seat fine you're late for school that's actually not a half bad oh no yeah i'm really it's like miss
I don't even how do you even do Marge's voice that's even better I am your character arc
hold on body watch me hit this donut watch me crank that Lisa
I hate this But more No, stop Can you see the video?
I feel like you're a force to work really well Dude, I don't know how to I crumble, I don't know I crumble Eat my shorts I don't know man, I don't know how to do this Oh, bardo!
What the fuck happened here?
This is like, oh shit What the fuck happened here?
Oh shit, there's a fight, there's a There's an AI war oh my god you launched him into the distance a.m versus ai let's go
oh no oh no get out of the car get out of the car it's gonna explode get out of the car oh wait what wait what happened to you did you you didn't trust me i mean it's true like i mean That side was a right to.
I mean, you were a right to, but, like, that hurts.
Oh, shoot.
Should I take it in high ground?
Your son needs help.
You're fine.
Look at you.
See, look at that.
You're so fine.
Are you asking for help against bots?
Like, I forget that they're incompetent.
Oh, wait, what's this?
I got super slushy.
Love, love, love.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that was unrelated to the super slushy.
What did I do?
What is that?
Oh, wait, there's chug jugs here.
Want to see something cool?
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Oh, you missed out on the...
I just realized I have no gun.
Okay, give me a sec.
Wait, what?
What are I...
Oh, I can aim?
Wait, what is...
There's a...
What does this fish do?
He's just...
Oh, the fish can give you a dash.
Try it, try it.
It's cool.
guys with this uh okay drink it you can do dashes i don't know how it works but yeah see whoa cool whoa careful there oh where am i getting shot at
all right nice come on we're gonna do it we're gonna win against bots i believe all right let's see i want to swap to all right let's go where's oh my gosh we don't have another I feel like I'm playing with training wheels.
Well, we're fine.
It doesn't help that I'm walking around in a giant suit of training wheels.
It hasn't been the same since the accident.
I wonder what even happened.
Skateboarding accident, I bet.
Yeah, skateboarding accident.
Oh my god, there's a nuclear power plant.
Nuclear power plant.
Let's go.
Didn't you hear power point?
Yeah.
careful when you move to the next slide it might be explosive you might even get cancer hey let's think about the positives about the nuclear energy like think about how clean it is think about clean energy oh true true clean energy with nuclear i don't we are we like moving away from nuclear power power plants i actually i actually don't know i'm just going off of what news are telling me yeah the fake i don't know we suede we get we all get our news we get our news from tv one two and four i get my news on twitter you should get your news on real websites like twitter yes i'm trying to find truly the best the bastion of intelligence yeah i mean that's literally where I got my news from every day now.
I know that's pretty fucked up, but hey, it's for you.
Wait, where's the, I'm trying to find, thank you.
This does make me immensely afraid for the future, but it's for me.
Oh, game could use upbees.
Oh my gosh, I didn't even see that sound guy.
Give me a sec.
Let me raise up the game volume real quick.
You can say what I think you said.
I did not, it wasn't me.
It was my sound team.
Okay.
My sound team was like the game volume meets upies and i'm like okay oh my god okay looks i have they have homers wait what the fuck who's this guy can you can we actually find his workstation yeah i'm literally there hold on i'm gonna see right here you see it's like halfway in the in the thing but like it's right here where the fuck are you i'm here oh there see look it says donuts right here this oh cool yeah that's where he works and now where is he did you know like it smells like paycheck do you know like uh what the fuck is that there's like something on top there's like oh it's like those like packages and shit on top oh like the supply drops yeah supply drops i don't know i guess it's like part of the battle royale mode but the mode that no one plays I thought zero builds fine but then again if you're not playing against actual people it doesn't really it's not your challenge anyways you build a fucking house in two seconds you've ever seen you've seen pro play right of zero
like I'm not zero but um but build mode and they just like I haven't seen pro players like but I have been in lobbies with people that are not pros and that enough is that alone is enough scary I remember yeah yeah because like no yeah it's so fucking crazy they would just build like a goddamn house it'd be five seconds at past And then new real estate appears in front of me,
like an apartment, like a new apartment building.
It's entirely gentrified, and they're charging me $1,500 a month.
Yeah, exactly.
And what's this?
There's like a bus stop.
How do I activate this?
You see?
Oh.
Oh, I have to destroy it.
All right.
Wait, it's this.
I'm trying to, like, enter this big glass house.
Oh, hello.
Oh, I did.
I killed the last guy.
Okay.
Yay.
We won.
We did it.
Our first win.
Yippee.
All right.
Let's get do soon.
Something about the faces there at the bottom just messes me out.
And just like, I did it.
I did it.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how do I have my dog?
I got a dog.
But like, how do I use my dog?
Is it just like an e-monger?
I don't know wait battle royale we're zero build battle oh there you go zero build I got it select all right we in what do we do squad and so we get paired up with more NPCs yeah yeah yeah they carry us all right sure okay make sure you turn up oh actually it doesn't matter you're not streaming is oh games could use more up you still okay don't worry i got you all right i think yeah no my vc is off because i've done like games with uh my members too and i don't trust them but you always get the best vcs yeah people people like oh yeah did you see the one where it's such a did you see the one in today in rivals uh someone was like I can't even say it on YouTube.
Wait, I'll show you the clip.
It's I can't even show it on YouTube.
Like, I'm kind of concerned.
What happened?
It fucking, it was, it caught me.
I got blindsided because I was not expecting me to have that.
That was wild.
I'll show it in chat.
I was literally just fucking vibing in rivals.
Whoa.
that is whoa I feel like I missed a few chapters yeah I was just like I was just like what the fuck like who is what I said it's like how does this keep happening I was thinking about this like another one entirely no and then the guy was like sorry my bad wrong person I got it who was the right person Who donkey bird?
This man, like, who is this person?
Who is this?
Who is this fabled donkey bird?
Yeah, like, oh my god.
He's like, oh yeah, I meant donkey bird.
I'm like, so shit.
I was like, which guy?
Which one?
What clip were you thinking of?
Is your evil nemesis cookie dog or something like that.
All right.
Town square we go.
Wait, what clip were you thinking of?
Yeah, I won't go to...
I won't show you the most.
Tavern.
It involves the D word.
The D way?
There's so many words that start with D.
Okay.
I will not elaborate further.
What other word could it be?
We come to most tavern with me.
We're gonna drink.
Alright.
Sorry, sorry.
Where's the tavern?
It's right here.
There's Krusty Burger.
Okay, there's Quikimart.
Look for my name.
I don't know how to read.
Oh, there you are.
Oh, there's Moe's.
King Toots Music Store and E-Mails.
You even do the...
Answer the phone.
Ring, ring.
No, you ring.
You pick it up.
All right.
Yellow.
Yeah, I'd like to speak to a Mr. Tabugger.
First name.
Get it.
Yell out.
I'll eat a bugger.
egg oh forget it it's the thought that counts i like it it's like the little easter eggs all everywhere oh my god and then there's jepadiah you you actually don't know the lore behind this oh you don't know jepadiah he was a racist oh what do you mean oh wait what i i'm not no sure how to react to you just kind of saying like i'm just gonna oh Oh,
really?
Alright.
Now I know.
Now I know that.
Wait, why is this guy just here?
Oh, are you a bot?
Oh, yeah, you are.
I believe so.
Yeah, you just ran away from me.
Get out of here.
Wait, how did you do that?
Watch this.
Get out of here.
Oh, I was gonna break it, but whatever.
Who's shooting at us?
Oh, that guy.
Evil Homer.
Wait, there's an evil Homer here.
What the fuck?
where's this evil all right grab this oh don't worry okay is it a boss is that what it is yeah it's a boss you get like extra stuff from it wait wait where are you so much stuff yeah they have these like boss like ai boss fights now or mp sorry mpc boss fights you can't say that anymore oh there he is there he is there's there's evil homer he's actually pretty strong.
He has a shotgun.
Yeah.
He's also very tanky too.
Don't worry.
I'm 88.
There we go.
Oh my god, he hits me.
I got reloaded.
Oh!
You got him?
Yeah.
There you go.
I got this guy too.
Close one.
Thank God.
I ran completely out of bullets there.
I feel like...
I feel like the moment we fight real people it's gonna be over for us I feel like we are not ready for real people oh shit wait there's someone in that bush no I threw that oh wait okay that's like stranger danger I'm in danger wait there's a slushy machine I still don't know what the slushy does I'm gonna buy it just because oh my god we're at the quickie wait this is not the quickie mark what the fuck is this is it not no it's called bird station there's a gas station in in springfield i actually have never heard of this yeah but i have seen like the birdie mart like the birdie mart what the is the birdie mart i don't know is that that not what it says bird bird e mart yeah wait i just realized wait a minute i just realized
Guys, how do I emote?
Wait, I got it.
I got,
oh wait.
You want to watch me crazy?
I'm sorry.
Wait,
you can join in.
I'll come with you.
I'm gonna die.
I'm actually...
Hey, come over here.
Where are you?
Why did you run?
away i wasn't ready i wasn't ready to you breaking it down and then just hit me there
i'll come with you come over here sandu i can't tell if it's marge or toad
okay where are you even going at this wait come on come on come on i'm hit with i'm hit with the I'm gonna get dizzy.
You're gonna make me dizzy.
Come on, stop.
Why are you running away?
Oh my god.
I'm just as cool as the kids.
Bro, why are you running away from me?
Why are you running?
I'm trying so hard to keep my composure.
I'm begging you have mercy on my soul.
why are we like running i got a key the key to where take homer's keys joyride oh you have his car where the are we i like how it's all of springfield too there's like the donut district corruption corners okay i don't know where where that's probably where mr burns is no there's there's burns manny yeah burns manny here what you would think that he would live corruption corner you would think so but apparently he does not oh wait there's a guy here hello there well there's a there's an mpc here goodbye mpc i'm gonna chuck him off the cliff that's what i'm gonna do next month in my minecraft session chuck them off cliffs yeah i'm gonna find a cliff chuck them out you know i'm gonna i'm gonna throw him in the ocean all right long live the king goodbye Okay,
slowly.
Oh, look at him.
That's so cute.
An NPC is trying to swim back to the shore.
That's cute.
I'm just seeing...
This is sadistic.
This is so incredibly sadistic for no reason.
Oh, look.
He's trying to swim back.
Oh.
You're very dedicated to keeping him off the beach.
No land for you.
I have my HP.
Oh, there he goes.
Oh, wait.
I gotta pick this up.
I gotta pick up the ammo.
Get the ammo.
You need it.
Yeah, gotta keep the beaches clean.
We're his friends.
Yeah, that's right.
Clean the beaches.
We don't want decomposing bodies in the water.
That ain't cool.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Our AI is fighting the other AI.
He won.
He won the AI wars.
Oh, he default danced on me.
Oh, my God.
Wait, is he a real person?
Wait.
No, I don't think so.
real?
Are you just going to be like, are you real?
Are you real?
I think Jacob C31 and detailed Matt might not be real.
Me?
Oh my god, he's real!
Oh, the real!
The real!
How old are you?
No, it's not appropriate to ask.
I don't want to talk to a child.
I want to know.
Okay, we got it.
I want to be sure.
not talking to a child it's real oh my god he's real he's looking real there's real people we're not alone we're not alone no kid no i i stopped myself i stopped myself okay i didn't let the intrusive thoughts win this time that's a fun conversation what is one time where you know that the intrusive thoughts have one and you acted upon it um do you have any fun fun instances of that happening a jail cell or a bedrock not quite what i had in mind but sure i guess that counts i don't know i've sometimes i just let her rip you know like sometimes you're just like you know what you wake up and you just think bedrock jail cell you know the intrusive thoughts sometimes just become thoughts you know like it's hard to tell anywhere inside i mean yeah at that point like if you act upon them are they really intrusive at that point they're just thoughts i guess yeah they're you it's who you really are in the inside you know yeah you gotta you gotta bring me field you find out who you really are
yeah well yeah where what's the most intrusive thoughts oh i stand a lab  sir labuboo i forgive you yeah i did love i did i did la bubu for karaoke you know the la bubu sign la bubu oh my god okay wait give me a sec man you're introducing me to so many things today aren't you i told you you missed out you missed you right i said some of this stuff is old though no it's not old i told you you were living like a amish okay la bubu sign la bubu la bubu la bubu la pubu oh jesus out of me i know you guys can protect me from the bots it's like terminator i'm i'm preparing all right here we go listen to the song write this instant in the middle of the game yes yes we're literally against okay what is this i gotta watch an ad yeah you hey jacob
what in the world is this is this ai no it's real it's a real song oh my god wait
why why i did it for karaoke i protected you by the way you're welcome i saved your life i'm a hero okay i can move holy crap i'm a hero i have so i have so much ammo what happened while i looked away and listened to labubu labubu labubu labubu and my chat enjoyed it back it back it back in my day we had we had crazy frog and gummy bear honestly peak as well thank you thank you for at least acknowledging acknowledging culture I appreciate it I also did you know the oh wait you know like Lonnie Island songs right you know like the uh yes so you know the Natalie Portman rap no I don't okay I only know a few of them I guess um okay so I saw that and I was like you know what I should sing this but then I sang it because I was like oh I was listening to this song like you know I was like oh wait that showed up on my uh phone like yet the day before the karaoke i was just like because i was just yoloing the karaoke and just like whatever i was seeing whatever the fuck i want i was figuring
out the set list as i was oh yeah we are i guess yay and then um so i was like i forgot the exact lyrics of it so when i was seeing it it was not very appropriate how do you make Labubu inappropriate.
Oh, no, not the Labubu, but the, uh, but the Natalie Orgman rap.
Okay, okay.
I was a little bit lost there.
I was just like, for a second, like, huh, how do you make that in the third?
But then I was like, oh yeah, Lonely Island.
Okay, I'm going to show you the song.
I'm going to let you listen to the song.
And then like, um, oh my God, I almost posted it somewhere else.
Okay, I'm going to let you listen to the song.
lonely island was like 2014 and then like um and then i was decided to sing this on stream not remembering i gotta watch this ad about eating crisps yeah look he's like so out of it he's like he's literally like 10 years behind meme culture right now i'm catching him up on everything he's missed out i've never seen this you've never seen okay listen to the lyrics I got the Zambubu,
Zambu, Zambu, Zambu.
This is very important.
Jesus, okay, 36 seconds of that is about as much as I think that I am okay.
Yeah, yeah, I sang the entire, I didn't stop.
I was like, I ain't no pussy, I don't back down.
You know what's crazy?
The, wait, I don't think, wait, let me see if the, if the video is demonized.
I'm going to check.
Because I don't think it got demonetized.
Oh yeah, what's funny was that people were like, oh no, it was got demonetized.
No, of course it did because I sang some crazy songs there.
But what's crazy was, what's funny was that, you know how I did like, I did, I brought back Doka Field.
I don't know if you know Doka Field, but every Halloween.
What in the gnome?
Oh, you don't know Doka Field, my hero.
There's clearly a lot of things I don't know.
I'll catch up on it for you.
But like, here, here is...
Oh, also, there's a game where it's like Sands and Garfield.
It's like a Sands fight, but with Garfield.
And it was the worst hour of my life.
But anyway, that doesn't matter.
A whole hour.
I can't, okay, wait, I can switch to, okay, wait, I can, okay, I'll show you it, and then.
I'm giving you so much ad revenue, I just want you to know this, like, I'm watching so many ads.
Well, you're giving the ads, you're giving the ads to the music right holders, so not me.
I see.
Not even me, I don't even get anything out of it, that's, but, um, wait, give me a sec, let me.
Man.
Isn't it funny that you didn't do the Garfield thing on a Monday because then you could have said man I hate Mondays, but it's Monday.
It's Monday every day in Dokefield universe.
So La booboo, la booboo.
I mean the way you made just
So every Halloween
days.
I actually don't know what Garfield sounds like.
Oh, he sounds like that guy in Ghostbusters, the main guy from Ghostbusters.
Oh my God, what was his name?
Bill Murray.
Yeah, he's literally Bill Murray.
Like, that's his voice because Bill Murray actually played Garfield.
Wait, that was him?
Yes, it's Bill Murray.
It's literally his voice.
I've never seen the live action.
version in english when i when i saw it it was dubbed oh yeah no this is no it's actually even like in the cartoon animated ones it's also bill murray and then what's my favorite people were like how did she get the how does she get the rights like permission from jim davis to do this and i'm like it's how it's parody law i'm dope if you i'm legally distinct
As I saw it, like, I was like, how did she get the permissions from Jim Davis to do this?
I'm like, happy Halloween.
This is my Halloween costume.
I mean, that's one way of thinking about it.
I mean, I guess I dressed up as a strawberry.
Not on my own terms, but here I am.
Happy Halloween.
I'm la-poop-poop.
Oh, my God.
Now that song stuck in my head now.
Oh, it's like a Sonic OC.
Oh, my God.
Okay, since your hyperfixation is Sonic.
Okay, whoa there.
Like, okay, let's not call it just whatever we want, okay.
Okay, what do we call it?
What do we call it?
I just like Sonic.
Sonic's cool.
Look, I am honest with myself about my hyperfixations.
I also don't want to misuse the word.
because like i don't know what like okay okay okay since you know a lot about sonic do you know okay i'm gonna test your sonic lure do you know storm the albatross of course he's probably part of the babylon rogues made his debut in sonic riders bro what the fuck bro okay okay but how many how many he have on rule 34 though now why would you think i know that not a real sonic fan not not a real okay i don't concern myself with that part of the fandom not a real one a true sonic fan will know everything about no no no like the thing is i am aware of it not by choice mind you i have seen
you know what yeah wait what have you seen what have you seen I'm not gonna say what have you seen things I should not have seen at the time that I saw them give me an example you type no I'm not gonna give you an example you can type it to me and then I'll read it out loud no I am not even doing that because I do not trust you that information will not stay with you okay what if how about we do true for it how about you like describe it to me i will just say i i saw i saw things i should not have seen did not want to see if you're thinking sonic's dreams collection you're thinking in the right way and i i do not care to see any more of it oh so like you know like when we were inside the character well not not that i mean i'm sure that exists too or is the feet one I mean,
there haven't been a few of those.
Whoa!
It's literally, like, if, okay, so let me put you on some game.
So, back in the day, there used to be this parody series called Sonic Shorts.
It was basically, like, these flash animations on Newgrounds that just made fun of the franchise.
And for whatever reason, gross-out humor was really popular with that.
I still is.
And one of the things, yeah, and one of the things that they just kept focusing on was stinky feet.
Not only like this, but like old children's cartoons.
There's so much of it that I think that someone on the storyboard team was doing side quests during the production of these episodes.
Oh, so you think they were like, oh my God, it's like, it's like Knuckles with his like, you know, like the comic book artist, the one that drew like Knuckles with his Knuckles, and it was like Nipples.
Oh, Tyson Hess, the guy that's currently like one of the main designers.
Yeah.
currently the main comic it's like that like his comic is technically canon now if you think about it if you think about it any art he's done is official now because he is an official sonic artist i mean you can't just retroactively canonize things if i if i was an artist who was a fan of something and then became an official artist of it i would canonize everything i've done i mean i do like when people sort of do references to like their like their personal work even when they're doing something big i i think a one of the examples would be like the director of the first shazam movie if you've seen it oh no but like i've heard of it yeah but the director swedish dude and randomly when i was watching the movie like on one of the monitors i just saw an animation that I saw as a kid and I'm like hold on a second what the heck was that turns out he he made it and that funny net animation you just put it in Shazam as a Easter egg and I was like oh that's cool I like that that's cute like
just be like I've made this so that's what you would do with Sonic yeah all of your OCs yeah I'll be like he's real now also got ready up bro this is why we've been in the main oh sorry sorry sorry my beat my beat We've been waiting for him to ready up.
That's a sound guy.
I don't know if you said upies one more time, but if I already did the upies yet or not.
I don't know.
Wait, that's good.
Wait, where is it?
Oh my gosh, watch this.
What am I watching now?
Oh yeah, another person that did that was Toby Fox.
He put like a homestuck thing into Pokemon.
Oh yeah.
I love it whenever he like talks in japanese because he always says one word in english what was that famous quote i forgot uh
oh god that's so good i love that quote it's so i like how you just ripped out the japanese too that in a while either oh yeah he hasn't spoken english in a long time like when i when like when i was i still listen to english i watch english shows but like speaking in is different it is it is different okay where we why why is one of the places just glowing green i want to go to burns manor let's go i want to all right i want to rob the rich Yes,
we will become to the manor.
I cannot do any sims, this boy.
I'm going to stop.
It's okay.
See, you do it better than me.
No, we're only good at Marge.
Yeah, apparently.
Marge is where we eat.
That is where we excel.
Marge and nothing else.
So many people want to eat the rich right now.
I think they might be real people.
I think they might be real.
Yes, they are.
They are.
Oh, my God.
We're not ready for this.
Wait, I just wanted to explore.
I...
wasn't ready to get absolutely wrecked yeah i was like guys these these look very real they look like real people i i'm scared i was under the impression that i could just chill careful oh my god you do not know how powerful she is oh my god i'm so scared it's miku oh my god it's that march is crazy march oh Oh,
wait.
The Miku jump scare.
Wait, wait.
Oh my God.
Oh, we're crumping it.
Sandu, I'm crumbling.
I absolutely hate it here.
Am I hit it here.
Am I hit it now, Zadu?
It's your favorite.
Am I hit now, Zadu?
This is what the internet was made for.
Oh, hey, my.
He's like, yeah, like, your bone's dead and we're just trying enough.
He's just like, oh, there's the dog.
The dog is on the floor.
Oh, my God.
Sorry.
Goodbye, Miku.
It had to be done.
All right.
I'm not.
I'm hydrating real quick.
This is so sad.
Alexa, play the disappearance of Honson Miku.
Oh, yeah.
For those who are wondering, why did we decide to call this Fortnite Mondays?
Like, I was like, about to say like so what is this fortnight mondays and why am i on the first episode and i was like bro you don't know about fortnight fridays it's just like fortnight it's like i was like it's like i know about friday fortnight from like years ago if that's what you mean yeah so i i was like bro it's like that dude who like interviews like the craziest people like the randomest people you know he found he like found the hawk twirl girl like she like went off the grid just like you and then she came back for fortnite friday man fortnite just has a way of like bringing people together now yeah i was like holy how did you find her i was so surprised because it's like she literally went off the grid you just spat on that thing i guess yeah i was like i'm i don't know i found oh oh Wait,
I gotta...
I gotta help this man.
I'm gonna help you, March!
Don't worry, March!
I got you!
You actually, you're getting better.
Progressively, like, getting a little bit better.
Okay, don't worry, I got you.
Okay, wait.
I'm a little scared.
It'll be fine.
Will I?
Oh my god, I ran out of bullets.
No!
Oh, there were two people.
I was not winning this.
I...
Hey, Karamo!
No!
Okay, so that's why I was assigned to name Fortnite Monday.
And the thing...
The first clip I showed, Zandu, was...
I was like, you've never seen a clip named three women?
Like...
And I have no idea what you were talking about.
but like, what do you mean?
Name three women.
I was like, just like and I'm like, Shannon, name three women right now.
Name .
Me?
Yeah, name three women right now.
Three women.
Oh, the Miku, Meiko, and Gumi.
Yeah, all right, name three real women.
Are you telling me they are not real, Dokye?
Are you telling me they are not real?
Bro, I hate to break it to you, but- Break what I'm so sorry to tell you this I'm so sorry Okay, Elbardo.
Let's go I'm so sorry.
All right.
Why are you still like blurred out in the lobby?
Why are you you haven't ready?
Oh my god Did you go back to your lobby?
Did you go?
I thought that's what you're supposed to do.
What you're supposed to do?
Okay The fact that you are delaying this and can't even name me three women?
I gave you an answer.
You're just not happy with it.
You literally named three virtual...
You named three virtual women and one of them wasn't even me.
That is so fucked up.
How can they be virtual?
How can they be virtually if I have seen them live, Gedokie?
Yes, but were they...
Okay, name three 4D dimensional women.
4D?
Because if I say 3D, I don't even know what that extra dimension is supposed to look like.
Name me three 4D women.
Because if I say 3D, you'd be like,
Is she 3D though?
I mean, sometimes she is, other times she's 2D.
Name me three 3D women.
Three 3D women.
Yeah, flesh women.
portman not made of natalie portman since you natalie portman yeah i'm setting the board apparently i'm setting the bar yeah like oh yeah like i don't know i think i could top that uh lady gaga is pretty cool all right and if lastly like i don't know who who did i hear on radio last time but my least the fact that you had to that was an instant and also like i'm here and i wasn't even Okay,
but Doki, you said name three women.
And what the fuck, Emma?
You're one of the bros.
Oh, that's true.
Good answer.
Good, good answer.
You're right.
Like, for example, if I'm hanging out with the homies and one of them just goes, name three dudes, I'm not naming any of them.
That's fucked up.
Why, am I not a dude?
I'm just going to say, like, no, you're not.
You're a loser.
This is what I would tell my friends.
Bro.
That's that's do do the bro.
You're right.
I'd be like bro.
I'd never think about you No jokes on you.
I don't never think about you either and that's how it goes.
Yeah, yeah That's what you know, that's a homie also.
I don't know why everyone agreed to land here because there's nothing here I was just yeah, there's sweet F.A.
As far as the eye can see here I was like guys, why did you let me decide never mind there's something in the birdie mark bird oh my god that's us yeah that's your store it's your store the birdie mart your shape like shit but that's us wait what look look at this it's actually it's bird for turn you know it's it's a turdy mark it's it's literally a turdy mark look it's 3d i'm going to a nuclear power plant like i was just like beating the crap out of the locker for people to be real people like i thought like we get to enjoy it see so i told you what i told you the bot lobbies were better so i i was so incredibly ready to just be up against like mindless npcs but no no i was like hey guys i think these are real people you're like what what do you mean no that's a bot electric kid in number 12.
okay fine i but i don't know when there's phone starts a phone i don't know when real people start showing up though so that's the issue that might be it no oh waffle no there's no way i don't think waffle doctor was real he was doing a lot of hopping yeah but i feel like ai i hear footsteps pc programming has improved a lot oh coming up coming from above coming from above okay okay watch this this is not a real person he's way too slow you kill him i'm gonna wait okay there we go i knew you got this pick that up what's his name what are your name yeah that's not real he just slowly he's like don't never expect oh i think somebody got down yeah i'd pretty sure you die to a real person wait where is okay oh my god we did not care about them let's go they were off on their own adventure yeah you know you're hanging out with the other homies oh my god okay can i can i put you on some yeah some weird music sure have you ever heard of clown core yeah okay so you have good yeah i don't gotta
introduce you to anything then we just passed a porta potty and my brain just went nice to be fair i don't room oh wait that's it that's that's that's the real person we're supposed to kill the other person was um oh oh oh guys they're real they're real they're real they're real they're real they're real they're real i i just stood there and oh they're so real they're they're so real we're don't move away from me i'm trying to get you up um she's coming over and you're dead it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine it's not fine don't worry the ape of i don't know far north south southeast there's some shit that's gonna save us What is the apes of FNST?
What the fuck does that mean?
Oh, he's dead.
Wait, he died?
He died.
Alright, no, I'm locking in.
Don't worry, Zandu.
We got this.
I will...
I know how to ready up this time.
I remember to ready up.
My brain, I'm ready.
I know they're real people.
Okay, if you guys are gonna...
If you guys are gonna stream-snipe us, kill everyone else in the lobby.
Yes.
Get us a...
kill everyone else in the lobby or come over to us and feed us heals like that's all i want or gold guns give us gold guns feed us heals and then kill everyone else in the lobby if we get shot at come over in a car and run them over we're on east coast we were talking about hit and run earlier so here's your chance yeah here's your chance to hit and run the one-time opportunity guys
do and I win is because of because we were very good at this game not because you guys helped us how do you change sensitivity like I'm moving my mouse a little bit and I'm like spinning it's like what the fuck is that what you've been playing on this entire time yes oh my god okay it is literally mouse and keyboard and then it's x and y axis you go you see the fingertip with the you go right different fingertip with circle and then it's the one on the right and then it's x and y you just put it out the same thing okay okay that's it there you go it's probably not gonna help me much i mean it would help a lot actually all right let's go here just straight down the town Not a coward.
I'm locking in.
Alright, Geronimo.
Let's see how this goes.
I'm gonna go to Moe.
What is this?
I'm gonna go to this random shop.
Moe's now with electricity.
Oh my god, there's Finn.
Oh my god, Finn's coming over.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is not fair.
Oh my god, I got killed by Finn.
I got killed by Finn.
Who's Finn?
From Adventure Time.
What do you mean?
I don't watch Adventure Time.
What is wrong with you?
I've never seen it.
What is...
No, Finn the human.
He's too strong.
It's because he's a real person.
Bro, I'm watching one of our buddies and he's just eating crusty burgers.
Literally, that's all he's been eating.
He's eating crusty burgers right now.
Yeah, bro, I'm dead.
Why are you eating crusty burgers?
I see Finn.
Yeah, no, be careful.
He's gonna fuck you up.
Yeah, I told you.
Jesus.
He shotgunned me so quickly.
I'm broke.
He got a shotgun and he just ran at me.
Guys, what happened to our stream snipers?
I told you, you had one job, guys.
Literally one job.
Kill Finn the human.
That's all I want.
Kill him.
End adventure time.
Bro, he's insane.
Bro, this guy.
Okay, our... Oh my god.
Our guy is literally playing on a controller.
Oh my god!
I think guy the one this guy's playing on a controller there is no way that's not controller aim do you think our squad mates are are perhaps viewers because they're they're dressed exactly the same they look no i think they're just i think they're just like hanging like we're on we're intruding on a date maybe i'd oh okay my might be sorry yeah yeah yeah i think that's but they do like squad because they like they like having people there
oh no wait you're still alive okay it's up to you i don't know about that i'm thinking oh yeah i know you're fucked no this oh yeah goodbye goodbye okay okay this time i'll i didn't lock in last time only because i didn't have a gun so like this time when i get flying all over the place when i get a gun i'm impressed it'll be different i swear also if anyone is in that lobby that stream kill this guy his name is brett expo and he's in um in in fortnite in fortnite don't just put a bounty on some random this guy is in spring but the main town of springfield right now just get him out of that lobby you know you putting out a call like yeah uh this player was previously spotted in the springfield town square if we could ever
I'm putting on an Amber alert for murder.
Oh my god.
Who is Amber and why is she alerting me?
Please murder this person in Fortnite in game.
The bounty has been posted.
The thing, what is the bounty?
What do they get if somebody actually succeeds?
Our recognition.
Oh, okay.
Zandu and I will call out your name, Exposure.
Speak my name, streamer.
Yeah, acknowledge me.
All right, I'm going to let our teammates decide where to go.
Okay, Led...
What?
I'm...
Oh, wait, wait.
Our guys jumped.
Wait a minute.
They already jumped.
They went to...
They went to the Springfield Town Square again.
I did not have a good time on Town Square.
That's all I'm going to say.
Is this the tilted towers of Springfield?
This is literally Tilted Tower.
No, this is actually Tilted Towers, but I do not have fun in this Tilted Towers.
I do not have fun here.
Oh, for God's sakes.
I do not like this.
I'm afraid.
I am associated.
I do not have a gun.
I have a gold gun, but I feel like I'm going to get fucked up with this gold gun.
God, I'm so scared.
There are a lot of people around me.
I'm in so much trouble.
Bro, I'm in so much trouble, too, bro.
There's people literally above me right now.
Oh, my God.
Hatsune Miku.
This is a good Hatsune Miku.
Kill the guy in front of me.
No, no, no.
This is a good one.
No, Zendu.
How could you kill Hatsune Miku?
Sorry about it.
How could you do this to her?
She's your idol.
She was the woman you named.
this woman look at her look at the sins you committed look at the sins you committed look this is i'm sorry miko it's all for the battle royale it's all for the battle royale i'm sorry okay we should probably go and help our friends we should that might be a good idea oh behind us behind us behind us where like on me on me on me oh my god i i'm out of ammo i have to reload gamer right there I'm out of ammo too so many explosions oh shit it's bad oh my god I ran out of ammo my other gun okay that's not our fault you killed Hatsune Miku and that was just bad juju yeah yeah yeah that's a completely like yeah yeah yeah okay so if you are a stream sniper please put on the Hatsune Miku skin so we won't shoot you and if you don't have exactly that's how we know yeah That's how we know.
And if you don't have a Hatsune Miku skin, put on...
Wait, actually, I feel like...
What skin would...
Oh, put on the default skin.
Yeah, it's either Hatsune Miku or the default skin.
Then we won't shoot you.
And then do...
And then do the default dance at us too.
You got an emote.
Do I have it?
I think I have...
What was it?
I think I have it.
I feel like I have it.
Everybody has it.
It is a default hero.
What even is the emote button?
I don't know what it is.
It's B.
B.
Oh my god, it's Power Rangers.
Like my crocs.
do go go power dangers you should oh i can join in even if i don't have the emote yeah they added that in so it makes people feel less sad about themselves yeah we're included yeah so you don't have fomo i don't have to spend money to belong no you do even though i did you still do uh we want to go we never been then yeah but our team wants to go to Burns Manor.
Also, the sound team, I upped the volume of the game again.
It took me like 20 minutes to realize it, but it's a lot of audio adjustments.
Yeah, because I don't pay attention sometimes.
Honestly, fair.
Why is there a hedge maze with a porta potty in it?
Ooh, what is this?
This one's different.
Weapon, weapon, weapon.
Weapon?
It's a pistol.
I got a shotgun.
I can hear people above us and I don't like that.
I'm doing a certain- oh- oh it's Spider-Man!
What happened to you?
Oh!
Help, help, help.
Um, hmm.
Hmm.
It's a lot to ask.
I'm so scared I'm really scared right now I hear so many voices around us or let me see footsteps above us oh shoot I'm in trouble I am in a lot of trouble
oh oh they're above me aren't they wait where are I'm coming over I'm just hoping that like I don't get shot at oh here you go
okay I got one wait these are bots nice yeah I was I just have no ammo so I had to run wait what the okay now I'm not I'm getting shot by 20 people give me a sec nice okay there we are now we can go pick him up all right jack okay now I know your dog bot.
I don't trust him.
Wait, can you body block me?
You can body block a bot, right?
There's a lot of people coming our way.
Oh, I don't like that.
Okay, that these aren't bots.
These aren't bots.
No, I could tell.
These are not bots.
Oh my god.
I got hit by oh my god, the edges.
What happened?
I thought we were cool.
We're together.
Gungnam Style to get here.
I don't understand.
We gannomed.
How could they do this to us?
Choppo.
We gannomed style and everything.
We...
All is fair in Fortnite and Gungnam Style.
That's it.
We're leaving.
Go back to lobby.
okay we're leaving i'm gonna take us to a real game what is a real game i'm gonna take us to a real game don't worry about it don't see that that ambiguity makes me worry about it i'm taking us to a real game now give me a sec i've never really like understood how how does it actually work how do people make other games in fortnite it's kind of like roblox it's like it's just like i'm pretty sure they have like it's like i think it's on unity or some should they could just customize oh it ready up by the way yeah octo okay yeah we're going to a real game i see we're gonna play a real game fuck these guys i'm not locking in they don't deserve it so what do you do is it just like crab game it's literally it's it's the oh wait we have to download downloading what is it downloading i already played the last time oh they must have added new to it now the real stream begins oh god or is it unreal engine oh yeah forgot it's an unreal oh i don't worry i haven't seen either.
I got too sad.
I watched the first episode.
I did finally watch it.
Like I actually watched through the whole thing.
Yeah.
And it's okay.
I got too sad.
It was so depressing.
The first episode is like, it is very sad.
Yeah.
He was like, he's like, you know, he was poor.
And then like, I was like, that's so sad.
You know, you know, I joined.
and I just saw the chat and I was like, oh my god, Jacob.
Oh yeah, when we were like, he's not real.
And I was like, don't say that.
I'm sorry.
I doubted you, Jacob.
It was so real.
I knew he was real.
I knew Jacob was real all along.
He got sad because of poverty.
Yes, of course.
Anyone would be sad because of that.
Oh my god.
Around the world, around the world.
Yeah, I think these are our fans because there's three, your Hatsune.
There's four Hatsune Miku.
Yeah, it's a little bit suspicious.
I feel like that's a little suspicious.
The Miku to regular person ratio is a little bit skew.
Yeah, I feel...
Guys, join in with Hatsune Miku or Dap.
Wait, there's...
Oh, yeah, I forgot they did a Scooby-Doo collab.
Look at that.
They made Scooby, like, a real person.
Round no...
Look, look.
Look at Scooby.
Oh, my God, you're right.
One of the world.
Yeah, look at him.
Also...
That looks so uncanny.
this or this just me okay everybody's just dancing to around everyone's just around the world wait what's going on why are we just oh shit okay it's starting you like my crap i love my crocs all right we're waiting for players to load um oh i'm number seven people are running in place yeah yeah it's loading people in i play this with my members it's actually crazy it's actually insane what do you actually do i'm you're kind of just throwing me into the deep end here you okay it's literally squid game don't worry i but i trust us it's it's literally just like squid and you got kidnapped into the in the squid game and now you you don't know what's going on you got kidnapped no i do not there are just things happening a
private show please tell me you
Do you know that video?
But like, you know that video?
Okay, so fuck that video.
But he's like, Marge, I don't want to run your only bad.
Do you know that video?
So when do the games actually stop?
Oh, I'll take, guess that's it.
Okay, there we go.
All right, it's the usual.
Okay.
understand how this works.
Excuse me.
Oh, God.
The jump scare was so close.
We got this.
It's just the typical.
I saw this episode.
Yeah.
I've seen this clip on Fortnite where someone would like play the, um, they do put voice chat on and they'll play like red light green light thing and it would fuck with people.
Oh, God.
Because you can use voice chat and just, like, play the recording.
Oh, my God.
I hear people dying around me.
Okay.
That Scooby totally should have...
Yeah, I know.
I saw that.
Whoa.
You can emote.
Oh, my God.
This is not fair.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
I'm so scared right now.
We do.
Oh my god.
So many people are dying.
Please.
We're almost there.
Oh my god.
How did she?
How did he die?
You're like.
We did it.
Yeah.
That's right.
Wee!
Oh my god, I'm stupid!
Bark hitting the Miku Miku beam is my...
Oh wait, hold on, I gotta join in on this.
Stupid sexy planners.
Oh my god, he's gonna take us out of the boundary.
We're all gonna die.
You see the stormtrooper?
He's just riding it.
Oh!
Oh, apparently you don't make it and you ascend back to the...
Oh, goodbye.
You ascend back to the beginning.
So you have to do it again.
But that guy is drifting.
This stormtrooper just drifted into the goal.
And I love that.
Oh, so much about this game has changed.
I feel like I understand nothing.
You said understand.
I think that was just like the game like a year ago too.
You still don't understand.
Is this how people hang out these days in Fortnite lobbies?
You just mess around.
We'll never understand.
No, I'm starting to get up there.
I'm starting to understand that I'm just like, man, I don't get this.
Is this what it was like when I was young, including Arby and the chief at people?
No, it's the kids.
People thought I was weird.
It's the kids.
You've always been hit.
Remember that.
It's the kids fault.
Wait, who?
All right.
Does anyone?
It is the children who are wrong.
All right, everyone.
Is there anyone in our lobby with...
Oh, wait, we have to go to the next area.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, it just keeps going.
It's this thing.
Excuse me.
What is that?
Where in the world is the...
Oh, we have to check in.
Remember when they do their little face recognition thing?
Okay, guys, one at a time.
Come on, let me through.
Let me fucking through.
Okay, oh, oh, I'm taking my picture.
I am a little worried because I don't know if we'll die if we don't make it.
I'm...
Oh, wait, where am I?
Oh, we made it.
And we're- no worry, we're just- we're just with the squad over here.
Yeah, we're with the squad.
Look at that, we the winner.
And everybody is joining in.
We the winners here!
This is the dumbest thing I've seen in a long time.
We made it, everyone!
Let us go!
Join in, everyone!
And the team!
Team!
Oh, what is this?
Oh, this one.
the four-legged race you must run the mob mentality all right this one is basically like a little uh oh it's been in season two this was season two so i haven't seen season two okay so they're all like little mini games i don't exactly okay this is okay i hated this part okay we got this oh my god this is a lot of people Is this a lot?
Wha!
I don't like how every...
Guys, please, personal space.
I don't like everyone crowding me right now.
I'm trying to speedrun this for some reason.
I really shouldn't.
I should just be taking my time.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
You can hit your...
Okay, I can get hit.
Alright.
I got this.
how many targets do you need to hit all three yeah what do you mean how many targets there's only three well i don't know if i just beat it to hit one
i swear sometimes you don't have sprint i think it's stamina oh no it would be lovely if they showed it to me oh my god i'm gaming oh my god did i make it oh it's the finish line let's go i made it guys oh let's go ah where are you i'm doing one of the tasks yeah i'm gonna watch it i suck at it oh i see you i don't i cannot play dead by daylight clearly clearly no dead by daylight is literally just tag it's literally just not even scary tag it's just yeah but i was literally doing the freaking yeah yeah you know when you time like the little wheel yeah yeah do you guys know do you know that they have like their own like little in-house rules for for tag like for a dead by daylight tag and like apparently like the survive if you like kill the survivors too early the survivors would just leave because you're breaking the rules you're you're not playing the game correctly because you're It's just like socially agreed upon rules.
Yeah, yeah, there's socially agreed upon rules where you're supposed to let the survivors run around a little bit before you kill them.
Because if you kill them too soon, the survivors will get mad and they'll report you and fucking leave the game.
Even though that's not the official game mode?
Yeah, yeah, no, it's...
And at one point, at one point, the devs made it so that people would get penalized if you kill the survivors too early.
and they removed it but it was fucking crazy you could actually get like lose points for for trying to win the game yeah imagine that just logging in not knowing anything about the social state of dead by daylight and just like okay i'm gonna play to the best of my ability why am i banned yeah all right yeah you're like you're supposed to let them play the game a little bit all right we gotta work together this is where i died last time in the world this is this is the best this the best part of the season two and this is where i died last time because nobody wanted to work together so what do you do so it's gonna go around it'll be like go around and then you're gonna be like you see these rooms and they'll be like you have they'll be like three people in that room and you can apparently kill if there's too many people in the room you can apparently kill that person and that's what happened to me i got ganged up on and got beat up in the in the corner I'm scared I'm scared we gotta
work together it's just us too we can work together we just need it oh my god two two I'm sorry I'm leaving you
Victor GG no it's just you and me okay all right we're good we're good we were yeah i'm okay i live did you live yeah i'm chilling i'm chilling with victor over here we're having a dance party yeah me too we could be bigger yeah we did it i've always wanted to work with you snoo snoo i've always all right i made it okay now now we gotta work together we gotta work together
Boom.
Okay, we look, you see that red door?
You see that green door?
Green door?
There's way too many.
There's, don't, don't, don't, don't get involved.
Don't get involved.
Don't, okay.
We're fine.
We're cool.
Okay, I don't know why you left.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
Yay.
My, my, my mate Victor.
needed me we got this okay all right we got this okay all right you see that you see that green door that's our door right there that's our door green door yeah that green door let's go let's go let's go let's go let's go let's go let's go let's go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go okay there you go we did it look at that see nice we I know look at that oh my god no problem with this you know this it's king of the hill wait wait is it actually yeah it is it's king of the hill do I look like I know what a trade pack is what the fuck
open the door what happened what happened to us we just we just came right here nobody opened the door we were just breaking beer I know what was happening oh my god what happened I'm spectating I'm not I got kicked out I'm stuck somewhere else I thought we
you unlocked the door and that's what What happened?
I was...
At
that point!
You will not be crying.
What the fuck is this?
I'm actually crying.
There are actual tears in my eyes.
All I'm saying was there were two of us.
There were two other people in that room.
And they could have locked that door.
They could have also locked that door.
that's up bro what the fuck is this game mode are you spectating am i am i just stuck like i think i'm stuck in the afterlife oh no never mind do you see this do you see it no i'm blue team yeah what's going on so we're without commentators we're like esport commentators right now oh okay all right all right i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure there's some of your fans and some are my fans.
So I hope my fans win.
I'm going to see if I can spectate.
How do I spectate?
Alright.
I'm spectating Velvet Vixen.
I assume the Miku Hatsune is our yours.
And then everyone else are mine.
Right.
Alright.
I'm going to cheer for the Miku's.
Yeah.
And then I get everyone else.
They're singing all I want for Christmas is you in the other room.
Oh, I don't think they're going to win.
Oh wait, they're the killers, I think, right?
I'm watching the Chris wait these are just dead players November so she is She's fully defrosted You're literally watching the dead players right now you're not even watching the catch no I'm watching it I'm watching it you were just singing the song so I'm like oh my god they're killing the hunt tricks oh my guess don't do it do it stormtrooper oh my god did you see scooby He just chuked the stormtroopers.
Oh.
I'm constantly trying to see what the stormtrooper is up to.
And I keep getting kicked back to Miku in the waiting room.
They're like, you can never leave Miku.
Kill her.
Oh, she took a quick turn.
Get her.
Oh, my gosh.
She is so good.
What the fuck?
Fastest freak, boy.
She's so fucking, bro.
She's just chuking him.
No one.
Oh my god.
Bro, there's a...
Okay, I think the kill...
Oh my god.
There are the fuck.
There you're so...
There's no way.
Oh my god.
Bro, you missed.
How do you...
I mean, there is a stormtrooper.
I cannot believe what I'm seeing.
It's a little stormtrooper.
Hey, of course.
Oh.
That juice is crazy.
Come on, stormtrooper.
Come on.
You can't miss all your shots.
Don't get out.
don't get out jukeed oh my oh my god he did it yeah you did it proud of you too bad he has to kill he has to kill two more he still has to fight that was a slippery boy wait all right let's see where is oh my god where is where is this guy i see spot him oh wait did he wait he got out the spider-man found the exit oh there you can do that yeah and then i'm back to the meek dancing oh my god look at Scooby-Doo what is he doing oh he won wait what yeah yeah yeah he made it oh you have one one Miku left there's only one person's left standing come on make me proud and then there's the Miku's dancing in this the dead room the purgatory room yeah they're having a great time let them have fun in there all right we have we have scooby-doo we have the stormtrooper oh lights out oh my god you can see them on the floor yeah yeah it's so cute i know that's why it's like this this game mode is so like detailed yeah what is it official or no somebody make it's just a fan who made it it's like a um
it's just a dev that made it what the that's a lot of customization that you can get to this that's cool yeah yeah it's like you know like those overwatch custom rooms is literally just that no i don't play overwatch yeah so yeah yeah sure you know i played a grand total of two times that's called playing what are they doing they're just chilling chug that oh are they doing like the the lights turn down the lights yeah yeah yeah oh he has a bomb wait that's all kill the hatsune miku no no she gotta win she gotta win kill her do it do it come on you just have enough good old 2v1 monday stroll this guy yeah bait her into false sense of security and then kill her I'm just waiting who is gonna feel the bloodthirst first.
Not you, right?
Do it.
Kill the Miku.
If you kill the Miku, I'll mod you.
Do not listen to her.
Do it.
Somebody wants to split the price money.
do it if you don't i will ban you
no no they're listening no
i will fire you and i will they're just saying like oh we can all win but i'm looking at the rounds and it's one out of oh never mind guys they were they were telling the Not them hugging.
They're hugging.
We did it guys.
We survived together.
Scooby and Miku hugging is my favorite thing.
I can't believe it.
We're in a dancing.
They're so committed to this.
I'm kind of a brat.
I told you this game was like crazy.
It's crazy.
Gallage!
What's the point of Squid Game is not about working together?
Everyone dies!
It's about having a strong resolve, Doki.
Oh my god, what is this?
Oh, it's jump rope.
It's jump rope.
You don't have a say in this, Snoo.
We know what you did, the crimes you committed.
Snoo's the guy that killed us.
all right scooby you gotta you're gonna channel your inner double dutch champion all right scooby you got this what would you do it for a scooby snack apparently not oh my god everybody is eating dirt oh we have nobody wins that's okay that that's it and nobody wins nope nobody won there's no winners everyone dies in the oh wait oh they get to do it again they get to do it again oh i thought i thought that was it yeah i thought that was it i was like that's how it ends like you know
back to purgatory yeah how much time did oh i can't even see the time because i'm no i can't i can't either i can't look that high like scooby is chill maxing right now he's war farming just sitting in a what do you call those bean bags Yeah, yeah.
He's aura farming.
Did you know that I actually have a scar in my body right now because of a beanbag?
Wait, what?
Okay, it's not because of the beanbag.
It was just involved.
What the fuck did you do?
It's a beanbag.
Oh, yeah, this is so fucked up.
When I first played this game mode, and obviously I got knocked out by the same game mode that we got knocked out in, I had to just watch them eat.
Like, they had a cutscene of them just eating a fancy meal.
And I was like, what the fuck is?
this i was just like is this it am i gonna i was like bro what the they get sushi too i was like this is so up i was like i was like bro this is up i'm just watching them have a fancy ass five course dinner like i'm gonna throw up i'm gonna throw i told you this game mode it's like it's so elaborate they're still doing it they're still i i was there was something i was gonna say but i completely forgot what it was after i saw that i told you i played this one time and i was like bro this game mode is fucking crazy
like in a way fortnite ended up becoming a little bit like roblox yeah no it's literally roblox it is roblox it's roblox but with ips with like actual ips what the is this i don't know this seems like this seems creepy yeah i know the last game last game is crazy that you mean that one wasn't the last no this was the it was the dinner before the oh it's the dinner before last game so last game is basically they gotta push each other off the off these platforms and stuff and the one person that survives obviously wins so yeah they gotta push each other off the platform okay so it's just king of the hill basically yeah and then it was so fucked up because like it was like copyright IPs versus like non-copyright IPs and I was like band together guys and push off that defog skin And they didn't have to fight in each other.
I was like, are you stupid?
You let an original IP.
This is about making money.
And they didn't spend any.
I was like, how dare you let the non-skin buyer win?
Good luck.
What's that saying?
Skins get wins?
That's what you used to say back in the league days.
Get Miku out first.
I believe in her.
strong i have faith guys oh that was cool scooby this is like that mario party thing where you got to knock them off with giant snow boulders oh my god they're like trying to bait each other too you saw a stormtrooper you tried to yeah yeah they're trying to mind game it yeah he's like oh guys i'm oh silly me i'm just afk right now Guys,
there's three of you and one Miku with the power of threes.
She's playing defense.
Bro, come on, guys.
Not that hard is push someone off a cliff.
I'm not speaking from experience, by the way.
You see, what this means is that for the platform to start shrinking.
Oh, it will.
Don't worry.
It will.
It takes like a bit of time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay, I thought the stormtrooper is gonna die.
I'm watching her.
It's a very generous platform.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, they're like, um, it gets a lot worse, obviously, the further they go.
Come on, guys.
Come on.
I'm loving that the Scooby just wrapped his tail around the pole there.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, they have to go to the next one.
And then by the last one, it shrinks.
It starts shrinking.
So, like, this is a smaller platform now.
All right, let's see what happens.
They're just...
They're not fighting anymore.
Like, peace and love, everyone.
Peace and love.
And then there's just, like, sounds of, like, stepping of everybody's.
Peace and love, everyone.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Hey, guys.
I don't know if you know this, but if you push them upwards, they go further.
Yeah, guys.
Push up, guys.
guys just look up and then start pushing they'll never know oh did one of them fall no no no they didn't wait let's just wait scooby's a double agent fucking push him off how is he a double agent he's trying to protect miku i see him you fucker push him off he doesn't deserve it i knew i knew i could count raptor boss 84 that's it i'm looking for you in my chat you must be named the same thing like i would be very surprised if he was very committed to like no raptor boss that's me yeah that's my username raptor boss 84 wait spider-man's did they killed spider-man yeah they killed spider-man how could you do that he was too punk rock truly
I didn't know the Miku's name so I can ban her when she wins It's an OGP dark bone OGP I know your name now Oh wait wait wait Oh Okay Scooby versus Miku No I know Scooby's a coward Scooby's a oh no they're colluding He's a coward He's gonna do it for a Scooby snack It's so over Like was what was it gonna be He was gonna do it for Scooby's now.
Oh, she did it for a leak!
Miku, what?
Oh, yeah, she gets...
The world is hers, after all.
She's gonna do a Miku-Miku beam.
World is mine.
I'm listening to the music.
It's so dramatic.
I know it is.
It's like, you could take...
Hey, I remember this from the show.
Yeah!
Oh, my God, it's so dramatic.
right oh you get your own mask you could be part of the team or you get to choose
oh what did she choose what is that is that the money i don't know what did you choose i don't even know what that option is everything is so mysterious yeah i guess we'll only know if what the fuck we're in the world oh we see this where is she in the void yeah i was gonna say where is she okay echo echo echo echo she chose she chose wrong she she she won the squid games and got to pick her prize and then just like banished to the shadow realm you picked wrong miku you should have joined the team holy that was fun i told you i told i told you i was going to bring you to another gate i put bring you to another game mode all right let's leave all right how do i get it i know i don't know okay escape okay return to lobby return to lobby it's at the very bottom there we go okay i think i actually might have to hop off it's Starting to get like 5 a.m.
here.
Yeah, you were like, I heard that, yeah, okay, how was my experience?
Not fun at all.
I don't know.
We got to mess around with bots a little bit.
It just happened that the humans started coming in and making it difficult.
They're like, how do you rate the experience?
One.
I also got one of those like, one, because I didn't win.
Exactly.
If I don't win, it's a one.
I feel like that's a pretty pretty understandable metric of success that most people have yep yep exactly you know what's up but that was fun that was so fun Zandu it was really nice just hanging out again you know like for sure we were like debating like I said we were debating on what to do at first we're like what if I just play a sonic game and then you're just I was just like oh i don't know if you want to open that pandora's box i will not shut up yeah and also like i realized sonic games take a while to complete as well so the one you talked about especially that one takes a while yeah so maybe in the future so we're like what the fuck do we do oh yeah someone was asking if we would if we would come back to dead space three we'll let you guys know right now i we i can't believe i remember when the first time we started Dead Space 3,
I was like, I never finished Dead Space 3.
Like, it's every time I try to finish it with someone, it just never, it stops.
So, we have to let you guys, we have to let you guys know that neither of us have the save files.
Where are we stopped at?
It's in a vault at EA somewhere.
It's gone forever.
Well, technically not forever, but, like, we don't have the save files.
So we were like, do we really want to replay it from the beginning?
Like, how close to the end were we?
We were like one part away.
That's the sad, like one to two parts away.
That's the sad part.
That's the saddest part.
I don't, I don't know if it was just me, it didn't feel like it.
I felt like we had like half the game left to go.
We were like, do we really want to play pack from the beginning?
like all the way back from the beginning to go through that that was like dead space three it had its moments you know i i like i like going crazy that part was oh yeah the the part where you were seeing things yeah you're like do you see that and i was like what i just see a boss yes you're like there's a body there and i'm like how's the how's the remake i've only ever played the first dead space is the remake anything the remake is so good it's actually really it's a lot scary i think it's personally a lot scarier than the original they like change a lot of they change a lot of things too that's cool that's cool i like yeah because the first one is the only one that i really played and then there was the second one where they made him talk and i was i was such a like child about it i was like they what do you mean he's talking that's not scary i don't care yeah you're like how dare you make it have give him a personality how would i self-insert myself as isaac now yeah but it's like
that's what makes horror games scary to me when i feel like it's happening to me like even if i know that his name is isaac if he doesn't speak i could be isaac yeah it could be i like it could be isaac zandu clark you know that could be near his yeah it's just literally his little middle name yeah you don't know they never specified one this mask in the second game and you're like now i can't self-insert myself i thought he could have been a woman in there my immersion is broken yeah my immersion's gone it's over
like how dare you have a personality that's disgusting is he still at least he'll be quiet in the remake right and didn't give him i don't remember honestly i just remember it was like very fucking scary that's all i remember he's quiet that's all i care about i'm feddy like that I just want him to be quiet.
Yeah, exactly.
But I had a fun time.
It was nice, you know, just hanging out.
It was like opening a fun little box of memories.
Yeah, and it's like, now it's like, what time is it already?
It's on closing in on 5 a.m.
But luckily my dad works night shift, so there's nobody in the house except me and the dog.
Yay.
That's good.
You don't get noise complaints like me.
I I have new neighbors that's the thing like like we like my dad does have neighbors Yeah like they have never like like I grew up here So they never once complained about any of the noise that I made so The walls must be thick bro.
Oh my god.
I must be so nice I recently I think I recently got new neighbors and like at first I got a noise complaint at 10 30 in the morning because of my Yeah, I know that is under reason people are awake at that like mad about noise was barking and i was just like oh i'm sorry and i lied and said i was sleeping but i was asleep but i wasn't oh my god because they're like i see because like i trying to i tell this in my chat but i'm trying to like not give in you know because then it reinforces his behavior so like i try them tire out but he's a obviously he's a weiner dog and they're the second loudest like they have the second loudest dog bark and out of all the breeds so it's very loud so oh no so yeah so and then like today i got another noise complaint today at five in the morning which is more justifiable okay that's valid yeah that's valid um i didn't confront them like they tried to confront me and i didn't answer the door because to be fair i was also in game so i was like i got yeah
and make sure i don't lose my there's a knock on the door but but literally while streaming i was like guys i can't lose my rank points guys i gotta keep also like i was just like all right i was just like okay guys i'll just be a little quiet because i also don't really want it i don't want to deal with that i think they'd be very angry if i opened my door yeah if it means anything i've I ever got in my apartment was when,
oh excuse me, I have hiccups.
Whoa.
That was when I was, I was too loud at 5 a.m.
in my neighbor.
That's the only time I've ever like had like a direct interaction with him when he like told me off.
And to, to his credit, I was being way too freaking loud at 5 a.m.
Yeah.
But then he's just been a jerk ever since and like, it's not like he is a saint either.
Like he drills and makes construction noises at like 2.
Fuck that shit.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
I'm like, if you're going to make noise complaints, then you're fucking hypocrite, if you do the same thing.
I tour in the morning, you know?
I feel like drills are worse.
Drills are worse than like...
Just...
Yeah, because...
Oh, God, my hiccups.
Why did I get hiccups now?
It doesn't even sound appealing and stuff, too.
That's the worst part.
Exactly.
It's just...
Yeah.
It's what my thoughts sound like when I'm in a bad mood.
Yeah, he's like...
And then the hammering.
on the wall too no I had that too yeah and you then you always hear that after too like they yeah that's so annoying no I actually had that in the morning too I think it's the same neighbors I don't know because it's like so close to me and I was just like what the fuck is going on but I didn't complain I I didn't complain about it I let it happen that's the same I've never complained directly to his face because I just understand that hey if you live in an apartment complex there's gonna be noises yeah yeah of course well not like I will admit not my noises though because like who would like you know like what were the chances of you living next to a streamer uh you're just hearing screaming blood murder is free yeah yeah also like that's dude because they'll be like what are you doing and i'll be like what can i say like i don't want to be like almost streamer and that's why i had my boot within my apartment that's right my chow is telling me to buy like those sound booth things but
like the thing is because I remember you telling me how fucking hot it is inside those things, but it's already really hot in my like PC room.
So if I buy the sound booth, I think I might like die of heat stroke.
You might cook yourself.
Yeah, I might actually cook myself as well.
Like I'm actually cooked.
So like, so I'm planning on, because you know, you saw like, because you're like, oh, just soundproof your room.
And I was like, oh, I should hire someone for that.
And you're like, you can do it yourself.
I was like, do you not see my DIY project of my VR stuff?
we should not i should not be handling soundproofing and the thing is you know like the tapes and stuff that i did for my room and stuff for the vr stuff it took me two to three hours so like to put that up you don't understand you don't you don't understand there was a lot of trial there was yeah there was a lot of trial and error it was a lot i i kept you know how i told you i kept thinking it'll if i keep putting more tape that's why there's a lot of tape if i kept putting more tape and I kept sticking on it eventually it will work so I did like three to four times before I realized maybe I should stop using the audio film and try something else something intended to be used as adhesive perhaps yeah so there was a lot of trial and error to get this to work and also coming up with the idea also took a while too so uh so how's the paint behind the if you don't mind me asking i don't want to think about that oh that side told me so much that side told me so no okay wait okay so i
should okay i'm gonna my my my skin suit's gonna be like afk real quick i'll take a picture of the wall the wall that got scraped by the base station and then that should be enough i see all right let me let's see it's focusing all right oh my god your is buffering yeah that's me every day look at this it's loading look at the wounds dokey why would you can you at least like yeah clean that or is it like actually scratched I don't know I'm too scared
I don't want to find out So I'm going to leave it there I'm going to leave it for future Doki to handle It's a problem for tomorrow me Alright here are the battle wounds For the one people in chat that want to see So um It's not as bad as I thought it was Okay but like there's a There's a one area that's chipped off But like I didn't want to show that It's just that's something for that rather rather the wall than you i guess yeah see exactly so you can see the the little uh the the battle wounds that oh yeah no if you look at it yeah it's a lot worse when you zoom in yes if you it's okay now when you put it like that it doesn't look as like you it off or whatever but oh okay they're like they saw the tiny parts and they're like that's not bad and i zoomed in or they're like oh we didn't realize how high resolution the photo was
it'll be fine it'll be fine it'll be fine my landlord doesn't know i stream
that one that's gonna be one hell of a surprise one day he doesn't do inspections You have a lot nicer landlord than what I had.
Yeah, he's just as long as like I pay my rent, he's fine with it.
That's all I need.
That's the best kind of landlord.
They don't know.
All right, I'm going to go in.
All right.
Yeah, just like the meme, they don't know.
Okay, I'm going to go and try to get rid of this hiccup and head to bed.
Thank you so much for exploring Springfield with me.
Yeah, Gigi Zandu.
Thank you for crumping it with me.
me today uh anytime like you ever have more star me memes that you need somebody to and to sign off on you know where to send them yeah i hope you had a fun time being not amish for a day and it's like it's been it's been like slipping into like a comfortable set of clothes yeah and i hope you're able to see all the love and support today zandu I was like honestly kind of surprised at the turn off,
but happy nonetheless, happy surprise.
Yeah, yeah.
But of course, everyone, he is not fully returning back.
He's just taking it slow day by day.
I've been enjoying spending time with my dad.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
And he's just been taking it slow.
So yeah, guys, just, you know, let him do things on his own pace, everyone.
But I'm happy that we're able to, you know, have fun today.
Enjoy some little Fortnite.
Yeah.
And Squid Game.
That's our Octo Game.
Oh, sorry.
Octo Game.
Gotta make sure that branding is correct.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
I will be signing off.
I'm getting very, very tired.
Do you have any final words to say to everybody?
Because I'll sign off too.
Like, I don't know.
Be happy.
Stay nice.
think twice before speaking your mind and yeah be nice to doki yeah and that's me all that good that's you that's me and i know that your dragoons are nice to you be nice to zandu as well guys and also everybody as always everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and move around and get that blood flowing and you stayed up for zandu and i head to bed because you deserve it i'll see all of you guys next time everybody bye guys bye bye bye See you.